monsieur le garde des sceaux bienvenue
bonne année à vous aussi
zéro le plaisir de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui pour que vous nous
présentiez le plan d'action issus des
états généraux de la justice que vous
avez rendu public que la semaine
dernière le comité des États-Unis au
logistique qui a travaillé façon intense
qui avait été lancé d'ailleurs à
Poitiers entre à travailler entre
octobre 2021 et avril 2022 et a rendu un
rapport complet sur la base de
contribution nombreuses de tous les
acteurs du monde judiciaire des
justiciables détenus et ses conclusions
avaient été remises auprès de la
République le 8 juillet dernier et c'est
sur cette base que le gouvernement a
choisi de se donner le temps de la
concertation une concertation étendue
afin de voir comment mettre en oeuvre
concrètement les recommandations émises
par les États généraux de la justice
notamment pour répondre aux
dysfonctionnements d'une justice perçue
comme trop lente trop complexe ou
insuffisamment efficace
au cours du dernier quinquennat et
encore lorsque on nous avons examiné le
budget nous avons pu constater son
augmentation significative de 26% pour
ce qui concerne les trois dernières
années et avec notre commission nous
avons été particulièrement attentifs à
l'augmentation de ses moyens l'appel des
3000 comme on le dit nous a fait prendre
conscience que le chemin était encore
long mais il est vrai que une partie de
celui-ci était parcourue et ce n'est pas
rien si la loi d'orientation ou la loi
de programmation que vous nous promettez
prévoit d'atteindre un budget de 11
milliards d'euros en 2027 très
significativement augmenté un effort qui
une fois n'est pas coutume a été reconnu
par les syndicats de magistrats
alors au-delà de l'aspect budgétaire je
pense que vous aurez les mesures
opérationnelles à nous proposer on est
dans une génération de pouvoir entamer
ce dossier qui débouchera sur l'examen
d'une proposition de d'une d'un projet
de loi pardon ordinaire comme organique
vous l'aviez dit j'ai quelques questions
que je poserai après votre votre propos
préalable j'indique d'ores et déjà que
je suspendrais la séance à tout moment
pour que vous puissiez aller voter je
l'espère pour le projet de loi sur les
énergies renouvelables je remercie
monsieur le garde des sceaux vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
d'assemblée nationale mesdames et
messieurs les députés je suis venu
cet après-midi vous présentez deux
choses d'abord mes vœux de bonne et
heureuse année 2023 mais également et
peut-être surtout pardon
le plan d'action pour la justice tel
qu'il est issu des États généraux
d'abord ces états généraux je vais le
rappeler brièvement c'est un exercice
démocratique absolument inédite des
réformes vous le savez il y en a eu un
certain nombre
mais nous avons ouvert une plateforme
parlons justice.fr ou nos compatriotes
se sont exprimés c'est un million de
contributions
j'ai moi-même parcouru la France à la
rencontre de nos concitoyens
et nous avons eu des échanges sans aucun
tabou sur la façon dont nos compatriotes
percevaient la justice et qu'elles
étaient les solutions qu'il
préconisaient ce sont également dans les
juridictions qui se sont ouverts
d'innombrables rencontres et je vous
remercier les chefs de cours et les
chefs de juridiction d'avoir participé à
ce débat citoyen qu'est-ce qu'ils nous
ont dit nos compatriotes deux choses
essentiellement
la justice est trop lente et elle est
trop complexe il faut l'entendre et
naturellement cela
nous oblige
ensuite il y a bien sûr les après les
consultations citoyennes
il y a les professionnels alors il y a
d'abord le comité présidé par Jean-Marc
Sauvet
comité auquel je n'ai pas voulu
délibérément appartenir
comité qui a travaillé en total
indépendance comité je le souligne
transpartisan François Noël buffet et y
a le bon Pivet ont composé ce comité les
deux plus haut magistrats de ce pays des
magistrats des des professeurs des
avocats bien sûr
et puis différents groupes de travail
que j'ai souhaité mettre en place
sur des thématiques différentes
groupes de travail qui ont là aussi
travaillé en toute indépendance et puis
deux grandes vagues de concertation la
première dès la remise des États
généraux au président de la République
du rapport de synthèse de Monsieur
Jean-Marc Sauvé en juillet j'ai reçu
tout le monde tous ceux qui voulaient
venir
puis une deuxième vague à l'automne qui
s'est terminée en novembre les
professionnels eux que nous ont-ils nous
ont dit manque de moyens procédure trop
complexe qui convient de simplifier et
également une organisation de la justice
qui n'est pas optimale
alors on a pris un certain nombre de de
nous avons retenu un certain nombre de
mesures la grande majorité d'entre elles
très grande majorité sont des mesures
consensuelles et vous le verrez au des
cours de ma présentation elles sont
opérationnelles et concrètes
ça doit comment dirais-je améliorer les
choses rapidement alors je vais
m'arrêter sur les moyens d'abord sur la
nouvelle organisation du ministère puis
sur les mesures en matière civile
réforme de la justice prudomale
économique refonte de la procédure
pénale revalorisation des métiers de
justice
mesure en matière pénitentiaire et des
mesures en matière de protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse si vous me le
permettez d'abord la présentation des
moyens et un bref rappel de ce que nous
avons fait je n'ai pas mis attarder
longtemps parce que ce que nous avons
fait c'est ce que vous avez voté et vous
êtes parfaitement informé de la
situation
44% d'augmentation depuis l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron 26% depuis que votre
serviteur est garde des sceaux
avec ma prédécesseur Nicole Belloubet
oui 44% ce qui nous a permis d'embaucher
700 magistrats supplémentaire 850
greffiers 2000 contractuels le nm
connaîtra une prochaine promotion qui
sera la plus importante de son histoire
380 auditeurs de justice et même 470 à
compter 2024 c'est une hausse de plus de
81% du nombre d'élèves on va poursuivre
et amplifier bien sûr cet effort avec la
présentation au printemps d'une loi
d'orientation et de programmation de la
justice qui fixera cette trajectoire
budgétaire ainsi que les mesures
relevant du domaine de la loi mais je ne
ferai pas l'économie dans ma
présentation de ce qui est du
de du périmètre du règlementaire
pardonnez-moi
bon le budget doit augmenter pour
atteindre 11 milliards d'euros en 2027 à
l'issue des deux quinquennats ce budget
aura connu une hausse de 60% et ont
cumulé sur ce quinquennat par rapport au
niveau 2022 ce sont cette virgule 5
milliards d'euros de plus à louer à
notre justice ces moyens vont permettre
de revaloriser les agents du ministère
de poursuivre et de finaliser le plan de
15000 places de prison de moderniser
d'agrandir les palais de justice en
cohérence notamment avec l'arrivée des
nouveaux personnels mais aussi avec
l'exigence de transition écologique
numérisation de la justice et
naturellement recrutement massif
s'agissant des renforts humains c'est
10000 personnels supplémentaires d'ici
2027 dont 1500 magistrats 1500 greffiers
et un nombre très important d'assistants
de magistrats et naturellement bien sûr
le personnel euh pénitentiaire en 5 ans
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
aurons recruté autant de magistrats que
durant ces 20 dernières années cumulées
le cap il est très clair et les renforts
vont intervenir dès cette année
mais tout ne se résume pas évidemment à
une question budgétaire ce serait
j'allais dire presque trop simple et
d'ailleurs le rapport sauvé est très
clair sur ce point il y a aussi la
question de l'amélioration de la qualité
de vie au travail je m'y arrêter une
toute petite seconde il y a longtemps on
a souhaité à la Chancellerie mettre en
place un référentiel de la charge de
travail c'était dans les années 2010 et
puis
ce référentiel il a été placé sous le
tapis avec la poussière
les personnes il n'y a plus jamais songé
je le dis comme ça et puis Nicole
Belloubet en 2019 souhaité réactiver cet
outil et quand je suis arrivé j'ai
souhaité porter un coup d'accélérateur
cet outil il nous permettra avec
lucidité de savoir de façon très fine
quels sont nos besoins et il n'est pas
encore prêt puisque il n'intègre pas
notamment ce qu'on a appelé les sucres
rapides mais quand cet outil sera prêt
on l'expérimentera dans un certain
nombre de juridictions pour avoir de
vraies réponses en attendant cela que
nous attendons tous avec beaucoup
d'impatience je souhaite avec les
directions bien sûr avec les syndicats
négociés un accord cadre inédit sur la
qualité de vie au travail et j'ai appelé
lors de la présentation de ce plan au
syndicat je les ai appelés à venir pour
que ensemble nous définissions les
objectifs d'amélioration de conditions
de travail et afin d'obtenir la
déclinaison d'actions
concrète en ce sens
notre première obligation
est celle de l'efficacité je veux un
instant vous parler des questions
d'organisation
du ministère notamment on perd beaucoup
beaucoup de temps au ministère à
compenser des défauts d'organisation
je vais vous donner quelques exemples
quand on est chef de juridiction et que
l'on a besoin de quatre armoires
nouvelles
il faut passer
par l'administration centrale
ça prend un temps fou
l'administration c'est absolument
merveilleux c'est indispensable
c'est parfois un peu lourd je souhaite
j'appelle de mes vœux
que l'on fasse désormais
confiance aux acteurs de terrain et
qu'il puisse dans une forme de
déconcentration
faire les choix qui sont ceux qui
impactent immédiatement leur vie
quotidienne je vous donne un autre
exemple les anciens magistrats qui sont
ici connaissent ça par cœur et ne
pourront que confirmer ce que je vous
dis on a un problème de visioconférence
dans une juridiction mais on peut pas le
régler la sur place il faut que ça
remonte en administration centrale alors
ça a deux effets d'abord que on attend
longtemps après une visioconférence
réparée et puis symbolise
l'administration centrale qui a elle
aussi autre chose à faire donc tant qu'à
demander
une fluidité et un effort à tout le
monde il faut aussi que le ministère
balaie devant sa forte c'est aussi la
question de la définition plus précise
des compétences du secrétariat général
et de la DSI on travaille à tout ça
j'aurais pu aussi prendre d'autres
exemples en matière immobilière en
matière budgétaire en matière RH cette
déconcentration elle doit s'accompagner
d'une restru des compétences budgétaires
et de gestion des principales cour
d'appel je le dis je le dis
sans que l'on touche à la carte
judiciaire je le redirai autant de fois
que nécessaire parce que un certain
nombre de craintes se sont d'ores et
déjà exprimés et certains si vous me
permettez cette familiarité ont crié aïe
pour des coûts qui ne leur avaient pas
été portés et que personne n'envisageait
de porter mais on ne touche pas à la
carte judiciaire d'ailleurs ce serait
totalement incohérent avec ce que nous
avons fait en termes de justice de
proximité et cela n'est pas fini la
justice de proximité je pense notamment
en recréant des juridictions il ferait
Beauvoir qu'on en ait créé et
qu'aujourd'hui on n'en supprime
je veux également m'arrêter une seconde
sur le défi numérique
l'objectif c'est zéro papier en 2027
alors me direz-vous
[Musique]
c'est très ambitieux c'est très
ambitieux mais si on tourne la tête un
tout petit peu et que l'on regarde vers
les juridictions administratives on se
rend compte que les tribunaux les
administratifs et que les cours
administratives d'appel sont parvenus à
cela et il n'y a strictement aucune
raison qu'on y parvienne pas on fera un
outil commun greffier magistrat avocat
c'est un plan de transformation que
j'annonce et qui aura pour but 0 papier
en plus cette écologique
réforme de gouvernance projet de loi
organique bien sûr dont il faut que je
vous parle car je veux ouvrir la justice
davantage sur le monde extérieur et
notamment il est d'ores et déjà question
que l'on travaille sur les voies de
recrutement parce que 1500 magistrats à
embaucher il faut que l'on simplifie les
voies d'accès les voies de recrutement
il y a aujourd'hui cette façon
d'accéder à la magistrature je veux
qu'on simplifie tout ça on a besoin de
compétences nouvelles on a besoin
d'avocats de fonctionnaires qui vont
intégrer la magistrature encore faut-il
qu'on leur permette de le faire dans la
facilité et je veux également recruter
vous verrez pourquoi c'est important des
magistrats à titre temporaire acronymes
MTT pour venir compléter les équipes
juridictionnelles
alors naturellement nécessité à l'ENM de
d'apprendre à tous les magistrats à
mieux travailler en équipe
avoir la culture de l'amiable je vais
vous en parler et il faut naturellement
que le nm soit réformé pour permettre à
l'école
d'élargir davantage le corps enseignant
à des professions extérieures bien sûr
qu'on va pas demander à un plombier
d'enseigner aux élèves de l'École
nationale de la magistrature la façon
dont on rédige un réquisitoire
mais ce qu'un plombier ne peut pas de
temps en temps venir expliquer ce qu'est
l'artisanat c'est une question que je
pose c'est naturellement avec
légèreté que je l'exprime mais plus
sérieusement il faut encourager la
formation des magistrats aux fonctions
nouvelles que sont celles de manager de
médiateurs par exemple et puis intégrer
cette notion de l'équipe je m'y
arrêterai bien sûr dans une seconde il
faut dit le rapport sauvé renforcer la
qualité de la première instance et pour
cela je veux permettre à des magistrats
très expérimentés d'obtenir leur
avancement au sein des tribunaux
judiciaires sans être obligés d'aller
prendre leur grade devant et dans les
cours d'appel ça c'est extrêmement
important
je veux également mais je vais essayer
d'aller vite pour que vous ayez la
parole et que je puisse répondre à
toutes les questions que voudrait bien
me poser il y a 60 mesures
opérationnelles je peux pas toutes les
lister mais on aura le temps et je veux
initier avec vous sur cette question
véritable travail de co-construction
c'est extrêmement important sur
réflexion sur la responsabilité des
magistrats également qui a déjà été
initié puisque avec le Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature nous avons mis en
place à titre expérimental l'évaluation
des chefs de cours et de juridiction
vous savez que le Président de la
République avait demandé un rapport au
CSM ce rapport a été rendu il y avait
cette suggestion on a souhaité la mettre
en place et évidemment c'est aujourd'hui
chose faite je souhaite également
pouvoir créer et nous l'avons fait à
titre expérimental des brigades de
l'urgence pour notamment aller
aider les juridictions les plus en
souffrance je pense à deux juridictions
en particulier à Cayenne et à Mayotte et
j'ai rencontré ce matin les volontaires
qui vont accepter de partir c'est le 26
je crois
6 mois et un jour le jour
c'est pour des raisons fiscales que que
nous avons évidemment souhaité et ce
sont des magistrats qui vont quitter la
métropole pour aller comme ça apporter
leur aide pendant six mois et un jour
dans ces juridictions en difficulté je
vais m'arrêter une toute petite seconde
sur l'équipe autour du magistrat
c'est pas une expression que j'ai
inventée évidemment vous en avez déjà
entendu parler
ça répond à plusieurs besoins d'abord
les magistrats dans la tribune dont a
reparler tout à l'heure monsieur le
Président il s'expriment en particulier
chez les jeunes une forme de solitude
perte de sens de leur mission et le fait
de travailler en équipe et susceptible
de régler cette question en tous les cas
d'atténuer les effets de ce de ce
sentiment qui est un sentiment fort
ensuite cette équipe autour du magistrat
c'est un vivier pour le recrutement de
nos futurs magistrats enfin c'est de la
pluridisciplinarité et il faut que le
magistrat apprenne et ils sont tous
demandeurs de cela devenir un véritable
capitaine un véritable chef de cette
équipe il y aura dans cette équipe des
greffiers il y aura dans cette équipe
des enseignants et c'est aussi un gage
de plus grande qualité peut-être et je
le dis de rapidité dans les décisions
c'est qu'un juriste assistant à côté
d'un magistrat
c'est une décision rendue en deux fois
moins de temps je vous rappelle ce qu'on
dit nos compatriotes trop complexes et
beaucoup trop long
l'équipe autour du magistrat elle a déjà
fait ses preuves c'est nos fameux sucre
rapide je m'y arrête une toute petite
seconde quand on les a créé nous avons
été très aprement critiqué et notamment
on disait on me disait mais il fallait
embaucher des magistrats mais je
répondais il faut 31 mois pour les
former on est là dans quelque chose qui
est de l'ordre de l'urgence donc on a
envoyé d'abord
1000 sucres rapides dans les parquets
puis 1000 sucre rapide dans les
juridictions civiles et ben les
résultats ils sont là avec les 1000
sucres rapides dans les parquets
il y a certains d'entre eux qui sont
dédiés aux vif violence infra familiale
d'autres qui ont été affectés à la
relation parquet élu
en matière civile c'est un déstockage
qui a porté ses fruits et la statistique
nationale les chiffres nationaux
consolidés c'est une diminution des
Affaires Familiales de l'ordre de 25%
. donc ça a fait ses preuves ça a
tellement fait ses preuves que ces
sucres rapides on m'a demandé de les
pérenniser on est passé de la
circonspection de la critique
une envie qu'il soit pérennisée et c'est
parce que j'ai écouté les juridictions
que je les ai pérennisé tout cela pour
vous dire que nous allons aujourd'hui
institutionnaliser et pérennisé les
assistants qui viendront aider les
magistrats l'autre impératif que je ne
perds pas de vue évidemment c'est la
proximité avec nos justiciables et nous
allons mettre en place une application
smartphone
qui permettra si j'ose dire à portée de
doigts dès le mois d'avril d'obtenir un
certain nombre d'informations sur le
fonctionnement de la justice sur la
localisation du tribunal compétent il y
aura un simulateur de pension
alimentaire ou d'aide juridictionnelle
et à partir de 2024 cet outil sera
encore plus
[Musique]
utile si j'ose dire il permettra
notamment de demander par le biais le
truchement du téléphone une
indemnisation dans le tribunal
correctionnel pour une victime former
une demande d'aide juridictionnelle
prise de rendez-vous par le conseiller
d'insertion de probation ou encore
rappelle d'audience par SMS sur le
terrain de la pédagogie je rappelle que
nos compatriotes disent que la justice
est en complexe
j'ai souhaité qu'elle soit filmée
mais il faut également aller plus loin
et c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
Pape Ndiaye on met en place un passeport
éduc droit pour enseigner le droit la
justice dès le collège ça me paraît très
utile et on peut aussi espérer que Ben
le droit qui est pacificateur va
permettre
à certains de ne pas s'engager dans la
voie de la délinquance en tous les cas à
prendre la République et ses règles ça
n'est sans doute pas inutile j'en viens
aussi ville on est là dans du domaine
réglementaire mais je ne peux pas ne pas
vous parler évidemment de ces mesures
que l'on compte mettre en place je veux
que l'on mette en place une vérité une
véritable politique de l'amiable sans
toucher ce qui existe déjà on a déjà les
conciliateurs les médiateurs j'ai créé
nous avons créé puisque ça a été voté
bien sûr un conseil national de la
médiation mais force est de constater
que cette grosso modo 1% des litiges qui
se règle de cette façon
je veux développer de nouveaux modes
deux nouveaux modes de l'amiable
le premier s'appelle la césure et
cette façon de faire nous vient
d'Allemagne et des Pays-Bas
j'avais eu vent de cette procédure parce
que c'est au Pays-Bas deux fois plus de
contentieux
traiter
traiter en deux fois moins
traité en deux fois moins de temps donc
naturellement ça avait suscité ma
curiosité on est allé voir avec des
magistrats alors procédure actuelle
litige prenons un exemple litige en
responsabilité procès en responsabilité
je dis que
allez Cécile
est à l'origine de ma chute dans
l'escalier naturellement elle dit que
non
pas fort de mon bon droit j'engage un
procès que se passe-t-il je suis de
demandeur il faut que j'écrive
d'abord que je dise et que j'écrive des
conclusions puis naturellement la
défense va s'exprimer dire et écrire
échanger les conclusions par avocat
renvoie souvent solliciter les
justiciables n'en peuvent plus des
renvois demandés c'est infernal parce
que c'est toujours du 6 mois 7 mois 8
mois tant d'attente absolument
infernales et en réalité dans notre
procédure actuelle le juge ne staturant
qu'à la fin d'une très longue mise à
l'état et regardez bien les choses dans
un problème de responsabilité il y a
deux questions il y a celle du droit pur
et puis celle par exemple de l'indemnité
qui est davantage factuel grâce à la
césure le juge intervient immédiatement
ou rapidement pour trancher la question
de droit
qui est responsable y a-t-il une
responsabilité s'il n'y a pas de
responsabilité ça s'arrête s'il y a une
responsabilité alors les parties sont
invités à aller d'elles-mêmes vers le
volet indemnitaire c'est-à-dire que le
juge il est recentré sur quelque chose
qui est très important c'est le droit et
personne d'autre qu'un juge ne peut le
dire il en a la compétence il en a Laura
il a cette possibilité c'est essentiel
et ensuite les avocats vont prendre une
grande place dans la négociation dans
l'accord et on va revaloriser les
avocats pourquoi parce qu'on va faire en
sorte que si l'on va vers un accord
alors il y aura d'abord une priorisation
et ça ira bien plus vite ça deviendra un
dossier prioritaire mais aussi dans le
cadre de l'aide juridictionnelle les
avocats ils seront mieux payés s'ils
choisissent l'amiable
et disons-le aussi
et ça n'est pas rien les justiciables
qui auront participé à la décision de
justice
l'accepteront bien davantage
donc voilà ce que nous devons mettre en
place je le dis l'enjeu il est clair
Pays-Bas deux fois plus de procédure en
deux fois moins de temps et ils ont
acquis mais pas immédiatement pas en un
claquement de doigts ce changement de
culture qui fait qu'aujourd'hui et bien
l'amiable a pris une très grande place
c'est 70% des dossiers et le 13 je vais
lancer très officiellement cette
politique de l'amiam on va faire venir
des magistrats des pays étrangers on va
réunir tout le monde on va largement
diffuser pour que l'on s'empare de cette
culture qu'on la mette en place on est
là sur du réglementaire ça peut aller
très très vite et naturellement c'est
selon moi de nature à diminuer les
délais qui sont les nôtres
par deux voilà l'enjeu ensuite ensuite
il y a une autre procédure qui nous
vient aussi de l'étranger du Canada où
nous sommes allés c'est la procédure
dite de règlement amiable
qu'est-ce que c'est
ici
des
dès le début on demande un juge
de venir
et de devenir conciliateur
de se mettre
entre les parties et d'ailleurs c'est
très symbolique mais
au Canada
ces discussions là qui tentent à
Lamiable ne se font pas dans une salle
d'audience et dans un bureau et la
difficulté nous ont expliqué les
magistrats là-bas c'est que ça n'a pas
été accepté tout de suite c'est un
changement de paradigme c'est un
changement culturel parce que le juge se
départit un peu de son impérium il
enlève la robe il va devenir
conciliateur sauf que il est magistrat
et que Laura attaché à sa fonction de
magistrat peut tout changer donc on
essaie de réunir les parties et une fois
qu'on a un accord on laisse encore les
parties le finaliser et là aussi on a
des procédures qui parfois sont traitées
dans des délais qui sont Records et qui
ont impressionné tous ceux qui m'ont
accompagné
il faut dire que
nous voulons si l'accord est trouvé
qu'il soit homologué dans le délai d'un
mois
bien sûr parce que si l'homologation
prend beaucoup de temps alors on a perdu
le bénéfice et je veux m'arrêter une
toute petite seconde sur cette procédure
parce que à l'origine on va perdre un
peu de temps le temps de la réunion de
la discussion de la mise en place de
l'ébauche de cet accord c'est la raison
pour laquelle
on va embaucher des MTT et des
magistrats honoraires
pour ne pas que cela embolise les
juridictions et dans la mesure du
possible ce sont les honoraires et les
MTT qui conduiront cette première phase
de conciliation
comment on va faire c'est pas très
compliqué pour devenir MTT aujourd'hui
il y a un certain nombre de conditions
et on veut impérativement et
impérieusement les assouplir voilà une
présentation assez rapide de ce que l'on
compte mettre en place je dois dire que
l'accueil qui a été réservé à ses
annonces et plutôt un accueil très
favorable de toute façon écoutez on n'a
pas le choix
moi je vais vous dire quelque chose on
ne pouvait pas attendre de ces états
généraux la Révolution la justice est
une vieille dame s'il y avait une idée
magique on l'aurait trouvé depuis bien
longtemps on a essayé de réfléchir
d'être sage d'être audacieux mais en
revanche ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est
la première fois
qu'une réforme de la justice est
corrélée avec les moyens qui sont
susceptibles
qui sont susceptibles de porter les
choses
vous avez pas voté le budget vous pouvez
sourire
bon
allez
on finit on finit on finit on finit on
finit on finit on prend des bonnes
résolutions comme l'année dernière
d'ailleurs ça passe nuit longtemps mais
enfin on a essayé bon allez je poursuit
bon voilà donc
sommairement
sommairement présenté cette politique de
l'amiable vous aurez vous aurez
évidemment connaissance de ce qui se
passe le 13 journée de de présentation
importante parce que il faut diffuser
parce qu'il faut expliquer et
naturellement je vais prendre mon bâton
de pèlerin et aller partout dans les
petites dans les moyennes dans les
grandes juridictions du nord au sud pour
aller expliquer ce que nous vont mettre
en place écoutez si on réussit tous
ensemble avec nos magistrats nos
greffiers les avocats les agents
administratifs tout le monde et c'est ce
que j'ai dit ce matin d'ailleurs en
présentant mes vœux
à Olympe de Gouges si on réussit à à
diminuer les délais par deux franchement
je pense que nous n'aurons pas perdu
notre temps je veux également vous dire
que je souhaite qu'on touche au décret
Majini parce que
aujourd'hui ils sont ils sont trop
contraignants notamment pour les avocats
je souhaite également en parallèle que
les avocats structurent leurs écritures
et on a engagé avec eux des travaux et
je pense que ces travaux vont dans le
bon sens
voilà l'objectif il est clair réduction
des délais la Chancellerie va suivre
évidemment l'évolution des choses avec
un certain nombre d'indicateurs et je
vous dis que il sera publiquement rendu
compte chaque année de la diminution des
délais s'agissant de la justice
économique je vais aller très vite
codification du droit international
privé c'est attendu par tous les
praticiens l'idée c'est que le
rayonnement de la France passe aussi par
le rayonnement de son droit c'est
également ouvrir davantage les acteurs
du monde judiciaire aux dimensions
économiques c'est la création à titre
expérimental d'un tribunal des activités
économiques qui va regrouper quel que
soit le statut et le domaine d'activités
tous les opérateurs économiques
concernés artisans
commerçants agriculteurs l'idée
également d'une contribution financière
pour les très gros litiges ce qui se
fait sur les autres places économiques
et ce qui permettra d'ailleurs d'abonder
le budget de la justice et en
particulier l'aide juridictionnelle
puisque je souhaite la revaloriser
chaque fois qu'une médiation est réussie
matière pénale je considère est un
instant j'avais quand j'ai fait la
présentation il y a quelques jours le
code de procédure pénale de 59 celui de
2023 pardon je les oubliés mais ça donne
à peu près ça
tous les professionnels savent que le
CPP code de procédures pénale est devenu
totalement illisible
il faut tout simplifier la computation
des délais les délais différents sans
toucher naturellement au grand principe
et on souhaite évidemment
un article d'habilitation pour réécrire
ce code de procédure pénale à droit
constant
je veux dire que le code pénitentiaire
et le code de justice pénale des mineurs
ont été adoptés
dans ce parcours
législatif et pour que les choses soient
bien faites je mets en place un comité
scientifique pour le suivi et je vais
demander au parlementaire
qu'il travaille de concert avec nous
poursuivre ses travaux j'allais dire au
fur et à mesure de leur évolution il y a
aussi un certain nombre de mesures
efficaces opérationnelles tout de suite
qui devrait permettre d'améliorer les
choses je prends un exemple il y a
beaucoup de mesures je vais en prendre
une seule en exemple vous avez
aujourd'hui un contrôle judiciaire qui
est ordonné par un tribunal
correctionnel
un mari violence voit interdire
légitimement d'aller dans la ville au
travail sa femme elle change de boulot
elle change de ville pour changer
simplement dans la décision le nom de la
ville il faut réunir trois magistrats
les trois magistrats qui ont
précédemment siéger au tribunal
correctionnel ayant ordonné le contrôle
judiciaire je veux que ça puisse se
faire simplement avec un JLD je veux
également je dis mais sont des mesures
on s'y arrêtera tout à l'heure et je
suis naturellement prêt à répondre à
toutes vos questions je vous
que le témoin assisté est davantage de
droit
c'est curieux parce que le témoin
assisté si vous me permettez cette
cette présentation
qui convient de prendre avec quatre
guillemets et plusieurs pincettes le
témoin assisté il est censé être plus
innocent que la mise en examen qui lui
est présumé innocent mais témoin assisté
il a moins de droit
or il a peut-être lui la solution pour
démontrer définitivement son innocence
encore faut-il qu'il ait les droits
correspondants donc je souhaite qu'on
lui notifie davantage d'actes et qu'il
est une plus grande latitude pour
demander notamment des investigations
qu'est-ce que je veux également vous
dire
je souhaite qu'on change le régime des
perquisitions pour les crimes régime et
perquisition pour les crimes il y a déjà
des mesures dérogatoires matières de
terrorisme de bande organisée mais
franchement aujourd'hui vous avez un ou
deux policiers qui restent devant la
porte toute la nuit
le raisonnablement penser
qu'il serait mieux utilisé ailleurs ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième ça
n'est pas rien c'est que il est pas
question de laisser de la latitude pour
que on dissimule des preuves ou pour que
l'on arrange la scène de crime bon il y
a voilà d'autres mesures je suis une
fois encore votre disposition pour que
nous puissions les évoquer complètement
sur les
rémunérations la revalorisation il y a
1000 euros les magistrats les toucherons
ce que c'est à compter de novembre les
greffions ont été augmentés de 12% le
personnel pénitentiaire a été également
augmenté j'ai dit que dans un calendrier
dédié je les reverrai pour leur faire
part d'un certain nombre de mesures
prises en leur faveur sur le champ
pénitentiaire le rapport sauvé suggère
une évaluation de la loi blog Pen j'y
suis favorable totalement favorable je
vais la confier à l'inspection générale
de la justice
développement de la formation continue
des agents
création de plusieurs centres de
formation
dans différentes régions
je rappelle que la libération sous
contrainte est entrée en vigueur le 1er
janvier
que l'objectif premier est de ne pas
laisser des sorties sèches c'est à dire
sans accompagnement dont on sait
qu'elles sont génératrices de récidives
et je pense que cela aura une incidence
sur la population pénale il faut qu'on
attend d'un peu pour voir comment ce
texte et son application se mette en
place bon je vais ensuite vous parler du
programme 15000 j'ai été à de nombreuses
reprises interrogées à l'Assemblée
nationale sur ce programme en 2023 c'est
10 nouveaux établissements
pénitentiaires qui seront livrés en 2024
la moitié du programme sera opérationnel
avec des établissements qui sont d'un
nouveau Jean je pense en particulier au
sas alors pour le coup la chronique est
particulièrement bien choisie ce sont
les structures d'accompagnement à la
sortie
c'est fin de peine moins de gens coeur
de ville pour permettre aux détenus
naturellement et bien d'avoir un
logement d'avoir une formation d'avoir
un boulot et de sortir mieux préparé
encore une fois éviter la sortie sèche
cette éviter la récidive tous les
chiffres le disent et c'est bon pour
toute la société je vous ai également
vous savez renforcer le travail
d'intérêt général je mets emploi et puis
je continue sur
l'utilité de s'emparer pour les patrons
du contrat du détenu travailleur c'est
pour moi une priorité je vais organiser
prochainement une grande réunion vous
connaissez le principe de ce contrat
vous l'avez voté d'ailleurs
pour beaucoup d'entre vous et ce contrat
il a pour objectif de permettre aux
détenus de travailler un détenu qui
travaille c'est un détenu qui serait
insère et on a moins de risques de
récidive voilà je pense que notre
responsabilité et je l'ai dit pour que
ces mesures nouvelles soient efficaces
et ne reste pas l'être morte cette
responsabilité mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est une responsabilité
collective c'est la mienne c'est la
nôtre c'est celle des magistrats dégréés
des avocats de tout le monde voilà moi
c'est réforme je voulais porter avec
enthousiasme et détermination je
souhaite que vous y soyez associés de
très très près un petit moment voilà je
veux
formuler au fond le vœu que les moyens
supplémentaires historiques et les
mesures que je viens dénoncer sur
lesquels vous allez m'interroger bien
sûr nous permettent tous ensemble de
restaurer la place de la justice à la
hauteur de la mission fondamentale qui
est la sienne à la hauteur de
l'engagement de ceux qui la servent au
quotidien et à la hauteur des Atlantes
des Français au nom de qui il faut pas
l'oublier elle est rendue je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur avant de passer la parole
à mes collègues qui ont chacun la parole
pour deux minutes moi j'ai trois
questions à vous poser d'abord la
première c'est que vous avez évoqué le
référentiel de charge de travail des
magistrats qui donnera l'octroi d'une
d'une notation adéquate en tout cas
proportionnelle à ce qui est traité par
les magistrats vous avez évoqué un délai
sans le mentionner est-ce que vous avez
une idée d'un calendrier prévisionnel ou
au moins d'un rétroplanning sur ce sur
cet aspect à nous communiquer sachant
que vous avez également indiqué que il y
aurait un accord cadre sur les
conditions de travail qui seraient
négociées dans cette intervalle deuxième
élément vous avez évoqué les nouveaux
modes de règlement amiable et je
voudrais que vous puissiez revenir sur
la place du magistrat et qui sera qui
lui sera conféré puisque la place du
magistrail nouvelle soit pour dire le
droit dans un premier temps dans le
processus de césure soit pour assurer
une procédure de conciliation et
notamment bien insister sur les
différences qui seront celles d'une
conciliation classique et d'une
procédure de règlement amiable dans la
place qui confir magistrats notamment
parce que ce sont plutôt des magistrats
honoraires voire retraités qui sont
habituellement dans les procédures de
médiation qu'on connaît
traditionnellement une dernière question
c'est que le Tribunal des affaires
économiques que vous avez évoqué n'a
plus seulement traiter des sociétés
commerciales mais des professions
libérales et des agriculteurs et donc
j'aimerais que vous nous dise que ça
peut changer en tout cas ce que ça
matériellement ce que ça peut impliquer
précisément pour des procédures de
redressement qui étaient parfois
applicables et là je pense à des
agriculteurs et ils pourraient sauver
les entreprises qui ne l'auraient pas
été si elle s'était retrouvée dans un
tribunal judiciaire en tout cas comme
elle s'y retrouve actuellement voilà mes
trois questions et je vais ne donner la
parole tout de suite à Monsieur Didier
Paris pour une durée de 2 minutes
merci président deux minutes pour un
position du groupe c'est un peu court
mais on va faire avec Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour votre présentation
passionnée passionnante et vous avez
parfaitement raison de prendre ce ton
parce qu'en réalité ce que vous nous
présentez aujourd'hui est totalement
inédit inédit bien sûr dans le budget
mais ça c'est pas tout à fait nouveau
mais c'est la poursuite des forces
budgétaires absolument incroyables qui
nous amèneraient si tout va bien en 2027
à plus 60% d'augmentation de budget plus
60%, c'est que le sable je sais pas si
d'autres ministères peuvent faire la
comparaison sur ce sur ces chiffres là
et bien sûr les états généraux de la
justice vous les avez évoqués avec un
travail de fond absolument phénoménal
jamais jamais effectué dans ce domaine
là moi ce qui me paraît extrêmement
intéressant c'est qu'en fin on est en
position d'écoute et enfin le ministre
de la Justice a conscience Duras
situation dans laquelle se trouve sa
justice la manière de le mettre en place
une deuxième côté inédit vous nous
présentez un plan complet global
réglementaire
qualitatif mais aussi des pratiques il
s'agit pas seulement de notre travail
ici de parlementaire même si il sera
essentiel avec des des éléments aussi
tout à fait nouveaux l'exécution
budgétaire la manière dont ça se traduit
dans le concret est un élément
fondamental la le mode de respiration
des tribunaux que vous voulez mettre en
place me paraît lui aussi une attente de
longue de longue haleine la réforme la
justice civile que vous avez évoquée
même si elle va remettre en position les
magistrats les avocats et ainsi de suite
mais c'est très simple ça nous permettra
d'avoir une justice d'efficacité au réel
le plan que vous présentez c'est un plan
dans lequel tout le monde devrait être
gagnant les les parties à un procès
parce que ce sera plus efficace plus
rapide plus efficient les avocats parce
que ils verront le rôle reconstitué
reconsidéré les juges parce que ils ne
seront dans un mode proactif très
différents mais utile et intéressant les
victimes aussi j'arrête là monsieur le
président en réalité notre groupe est
extrêmement favorable à cette réforme
c'est celle qui nous permettra d'avoir
une justice plus protecteur plus
efficace plus proche plus rapide merci
Monsieur Jordan Guitton
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la situation de notre pays
exige une lutte accrue et massive contre
la délinquance avec une vision de
fermeté selon l'Insee 40% des personnes
condamnées en 2019 était en état de
récidive ou de réitération la synthèse
des états généraux de la justice
affirmait la nécessité d'une réforme
systémique notamment sur l'application
des peines vous l'oubliez volontairement
la situation de nos établissements
pénitentiaires est alarmante en
particulier sur la surpopulation
carcérale aujourd'hui 48 prisons
affichent un seuil d'occupation
supérieur à 150% et parfois même
supérieur à 200% comme à Carcassonne ou
à Bordeaux de ce fait la justice est
devenue laxiste car à vouloir trop
aménager et diminuer les peines par
manque de place on ne fait que libérer
trop tôt des individus que n'ont pas eu
le temps de purger leur peine vous
proposez donc la création de 15 une
nouvelle place de prison à l'horizon
2027 mais vous ne rattrapez que le
retard pris depuis des années monsieur
le ministre votre prédécesseur madame
Belloubet avait une solution elle pour
libérer des places de prison tout
simplement les vidéos car elles comme
elle l'a fait au début de la crise
sanitaire c'était un scandale chaque
année la population carcérale augmente
de 4 % les places de prison qui seront
créées ne suffiront pas et le taux
d'occupation restera globalement le même
vous le savez très bien ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'aucun magistrats de main ne
juge une personne en sachant qu'une
prison est pleine car son jugement n'en
sera qu'atténué et la justice laxiste
les magistrats doivent pour incarcé un
individu dangereux pour nos compatriotes
c'est le principe d'une justice qui
protège en bref vous avez la enfin la
volonté de construire des passes de
prison vous avez enfin pris conscience
que la délinquance augmente et que la
frison protège vous donnez raison au
Costa du rassemblement national vous
êtes presque connecté au réel de par la
réalité d'un sécurité mais deux ans et
demi pour arriver à ça pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas proposé une réforme
beaucoup plus tôt deux ans et demi dans
l'attente alors mes questions sont
simples allez vous réduire les
aménagements de peine remettant Palace
des peines planchées exclure de France
les étrangers qui peuplent nos prisons
pour libérer des places interdire
l'aménagement de peine pour les
individus condamnés pour atteinte aux
personnes finalement faire ce que les
Français réclament une justice fermée
efficace qui nous protège avec des
individus qui purent vraiment leur peine
merci
après mais juste pour information le
plan de 15000 et vous n'étiez
certainement pas là sur le précédent
quinquennat mais le point 15000 a déjà 5
ans et on a déjà inauguré 3600 places de
prison sur ce plan donc il est il est
déjà largement éprouvé madame Elisa
Martin
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
gardeesseau on a eu l'occasion de vous
entendre à l'instant d'entendre votre
conférence de presse et nous pensons que
la première chose que nous avons à
saisir au début de ce qui paraît être
l'examen d'une nouvelle loi de
programmation pour la justice qu'elle
serait votre
philosophie et il est vrai quelque chose
qui n'est pas simple à déterminer tant
vous embrasser de sujets
oserais-je dire que tout ça est un peu
fourre-tout mais bien sûr je ne le dirai
pas trois éléments paraissent se
détacher le premier c'est cette idée
selon laquelle l'efficacité de la
justice est soluble dans la rapidité
nous pensons qu'il ne faut pas confondre
mais justesse vitesse pardon et
précipitations une justice pénale qui à
nouveau va connaître des modifications
du code pénal celle-ci serait adoptée
donc par ordonnance
cela signifie deux choses d'abord une
question démocratique nous serons donc
exclues des décisions finales en tant
que représentation nationale mais ça
signifie aussi qu'on va remettre une
énième couche de changement du code
pénal sans avoir analysé les impacts des
du code de procédure pénale merci de me
corriger comme comme vous le faites et
donc à nouveau on va remettre une couche
de modification sur le code de procédure
pénale sans avoir été analysé les
changements précédents il nous semble
aussi qu'il faut veiller à agir au bon
endroit avec les bons outils nous
interrogeons le lien entre la PJJ et le
ministère de l'armée ce qui nous paraît
important dans cette affaire là c'est la
situation que connaît la justice civile
celle qui représente la part la plus
importante de l'activité judiciaire
cette justice du quotidien cette justice
disons modeste à laquelle
majoritairement heureusement les
Français sont confrontés là aussi vous
vous allez vers le de procédure amiable
comme c'était déjà le cas en 2018 ça a
été analysé en matière de divorce et on
s'aperçoit que cela ne marche pas
vraiment particulièrement quand il y a
des enfants le temps est nécessaire pour
réfléchir prendre les bonnes décisions
et on voit les couples revenir devant
les tribunaux merci
Monsieur Philippe Gosselin merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci de cette exposé on a une
justice en France qui est en souffrance
sur le plan interne des magistrats qui
ne vont pas bien des avocats qui doutent
des prisons qui sont surchargées et puis
des concitoyens qui trouvent que tout
est complexe et la justice beaucoup trop
lente donc le constat est partagé je
n'en doute pas un certain nombre de
préconisations qui pour une part vont
dans le bon sens et il faut rapprocher
effectivement la justice de nos
concitoyens c'est très bien gagner du
temps réinventer peut-être est-ce que
c'est une de vos ambitions je pose la
question réinventer la justice de paix
peut-être que ce modèle qui a été celui
de la 4e République jusqu'au début de la
5e serait à revoir pour l'adapter à
notre temps vous évoquez une refonte des
procédures pénales de la procédure
pénale question est-ce que ça sera
l'occasion de pousser la numérisation de
la procédure là aussi c'est un gain de
temps phénoménal mais on en parle
monsieur le ministre depuis longtemps
c'est l'arlésienne et entre Beauvau et
votre ministère il y a parfois des
sous-pentes qui communiquent peu entre
elles je me réjouis de voir réaffirmer
la construction d'un certain nombre de
places de prison mais effectivement
monsieur le Président
si on a une inauguré 3000 places de
prison du plan précédent enfin qui est
toujours l'actuel 3000 ce n'est que 20%
du fameux plan qui nous était vendus il
y a déjà trois quatre ans donc c'est
assez insuffisant comment comptez-vous
faire pour accélérer les choses est-ce
que vous comptez monsieur le ministre
aussi rétablir les peines plancher c'est
un sujet qui est évidemment important et
je me réjouis par ailleurs de voir aussi
que vous cherchez à à travailler
davantage pour que en prison puisse
travailler davantage on avait avec la
mandature précédente fait un beau
travail et autour de la Présidente il y
a LeBron pivée sur ce point et
la voisine Laurence finicianski sans
oublier Stéphane Mazar et puis petite
question qui est peut-être plus
technique et je termine là-dessus vous
allez créer sans doute un tribunal des
affaires économiques le temps je termine
juste la question monsieur le Président
et je vais très vite est-ce la fin des
beaux ruraux puisque les questions
agricoles semblent-ils pourraient être
porté voilà je vous remercie monsieur
alors Monsieur Balanant n'est pas
présent donc madame Cécile est meilleur
non mais alors vous en faites pas il y a
encore trois orateurs et à la fin de
l'orateur socialiste en séance je
suspendrais madame
merci merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre à
mon tour de vous présenter nos vœux pour
l'année 2023 vous dire que les états
généraux de la Justice ont dressé un
constat d'une extrême gravité certes
mais nos compatriotes ont également se
sont émus également de deux autres
choses dont on ne parle peu qui sont
d'abord le coût de l'accès à la justice
et en particulier l'appel on doit
s'interroger de savoir si le coup n'est
pas rédhibitoire pour un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens et sur l'exécution
des jugements parce qu'il ne suffit pas
d'aller au jugement il faut encore que
ce jugement soit exécuté il me semble là
aussi qu'il faut que nous fassions
preuve d'invention sur cette question
alors sur les mesures que vous nous
proposez nous nous considérons qu'il y a
un grand nombre de bonnes mesures et que
c'est un discours nous semble-t-il sur
le fonctionnement de la justice sur son
organisation sur sa façon de travailler
d'appréhender la question du litige vous
y ajoutez des financements et vous avez
affiché et vous essayez d'y répondre me
semble-t-il à un objectif d'efficacité
de la justice en mettant en avant la
nécessité d'un référentiel d'activité
qui nous paraît à nous un peu surprenant
d'attendre 2023 pour avoir un
référentiel sur la charge d'activité de
chacun des magistrats je m'étonne que
dans les tribunaux on ne se soit pas
émus de cette question et que sur une
évaluation annuelle nous nous envoyons
pas poser la question de savoir quel
était les contrats d'objectifs et la
charge d'activité que un magistrat est
en capacité de de d'absorber alors
sur le code de procédure pénale je pense
que c'est très écriture est
indispensable le choix de l'ordonnance
pose bien sûr problème puisque il s'agit
des droits de la défense il nous faudra
être extrêmement vigilant là-dessus et
compter sur un esprit d'ouverture de la
Chancellerie pour travailler sur ce
sujet moi j'ai deux observations c'est
sur le pénitentiel parce que elle n'est
pas vraiment traitée il me semble que le
dispositif que nous avions mis en place
avec Nicole Belloubet pour régler la
question du covid
avait satisfaite intelligence pourquoi
n'envisage une envisageons nous pas de
revenir à ce dispositif
donc suspendre la séance pour que vous
puissiez rejoindre la commission pour
rejoindre la séance pour voter on se
retrouve après le vote dans 10 minutes
il y a encore quatre orateurs qui seront
inscrits pour les groupes et le ministre
vous répondra
Monsieur Philippe Pradal pour deux
minutes
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues je
sacrifie deux minutes de mon temps de
parole pour vous présenter tous mes
meilleurs vœux une très bonne année une
année calme et apaisée pour des travaux
au service de nos concitoyens avec une
technique qui marche aujourd'hui nous
avons entendu monsieur le garde des
sceaux la restitution des travaux et des
décisions prises qui ont été rendues
publiques par vous à l'issue des états
généraux de la justice et je vous laisse
saluer à la fois la méthode et l'effort
qui a été réalisé puisque la réforme de
la justice ou l'avait rappelé à
plusieurs reprises ne peut se faire
qu'avec les magistrats avec les
justiciables la méthode a été retenue
malgré une année pour laquelle un
certain nombre de personnes ont eu
d'autres occupations les conclusions
sont au rendez-vous et je vous remercie
à la fois d'avoir conduit ce chantier de
nous avoir présenté les conclusions
devant notre commission je ne reviendrai
pas sur les moyens nouveaux
le maintien de l'effort qui a été
consenti et qui sera matérialisé loi de
finances après le loi de finances c'est
en effet nécessaire pour aller vers la
justice de qualité que nos concitoyens
je me permettrai juste d'intervenir sur
deux points particuliers le premier le
rapport sauvé qui a été évoqué et pointe
notamment le fait qu'un certain nombre
un grand nombre de lois pardon peuvent
être adoptés etc et je voudrais revenir
sur le sujet qui est pas directement en
lien avec les états généraux de la
justice mais qui est en lien avec l'état
de notre droite sur la difficulté à
obtenir parfois les décrets
d'application sur un certain nombre de
textes qui complique considérablement la
pédagogie que nous pouvons effectuer sur
l'effectivité de la loi donc du droit et
la confiance que peuvent avoir nos
concitoyens dans l'ensemble de notre
appareil juridique l'autre point c'est
concernant les réformes procédurales
bien sûr nous nous inscrivons
complètement au niveau du groupe horizon
et à parenté dans la politique de
l'amiable que vous souhaitez développer
nous pensons que c'est une piste
extrêmement intéressante qu'il faut
développer sur la justice civile qui
bien souvent peut par l'intermédiaire de
la médiation aboutir à des décisions
satisfaisantes rapides et efficace et
enfin vous demandez concernant la
procédure pénale en matière de TIG quels
sont les axes de développement de CTIG
dont le succès ne semble pas être au
rendez-vous monsieur jérémyordanov
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux Châtelet
il y a dans le plan d'action présenté
des mesures discutables et des silences
peut-être plus discutable encore
je ne vous ai pas entendu par exemple
sur la réforme du statut du parquet une
grande réforme de la justice ne peut
omettre la question de l'indépendance du
parquet une question de principe c'est
attendue c'est consensuel vous dites
vouloir restaurer la confiance des
citoyens dans la justice alors pourquoi
ne pas rompre enfin avec la dépendance
dans laquelle sont placés les procureurs
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif le rapport
sauvez vous le recommande quel est le
sens de cette oubli ensuite nous sommes
inquiets de l'option retenu en matière
civile pour raccourcir les délais vous
l'avez dit maintes fois vous proposez de
finalement contourner les tribunaux avec
une politique de l'amiable
c'est vrai tout particulièrement pour le
dispositif de la césure que vous voulez
introduire dans notre droit comment
faire en sorte qu'une des parties
n'impose pas sa solution à l'autre
les parties sont rarement armégal elles
n'ont ni la même connaissance technique
ni les mêmes moyens économiques et ce
rapport inégal peut conduire à un
résultat inéquitable pour ne pas dire
injuste quelles sont les garanties que
vous apporterez pour prévenir ce risque
de déséquilibre
en matière pénale sur la question de
l'unification des cas d'enquêtes on a le
sentiment vous souhaitez aligner
l'enquête préliminaire sur l'enquête de
flagrance qui serait un affaiblissement
de la procédure et donc du droit on
aimerait avoir une clarification sur ce
point et vous annoncez vouloir le faire
par voie d'ordonnance n'est-ce pas
contradictoire avec votre promesse de la
refonte du code de produire pénale par
ordonnance mais à droite constant
dernier point sur la lutte contre la
surpopulation carcérale
il y a un mécanique de régulation qui a
été qui a fonctionné pendant la crise
sanitaire c'est aussi une
préconisation du rapport sauvé pourquoi
c'est encore un des silences de cette de
cette loi pourquoi ne pas le formaliser
par un mécanisme dans la loi je vous
remercie
merci Madame aussi
merci
monsieur le ministre je vais être assez
terre à terre puisqu'en 2018 déjà avant
la loi de programmation il y avait
plusieurs professionnels de justice qui
interpellaient sur sur l'état des
tribunaux et malheureusement il continue
de le faire malgré cette loi de
programmation donc moi j'ai envie de
savoir en prenant un cas particulier et
il est particulier vraiment c'est celui
du tribunal de Nanterre pour savoir ce
que vous allez pouvoir changer et
rapidement pour pour ce tribunal au mois
de novembre au barreau les barreaux le
barreau des Hauts-de-Seine et
l'association des magistrats du tribunal
judiciaire de Nanterre décidé de former
devant le Conseil d'État un recours pour
excès de pouvoir
une procédure inédite lancée pour
dénoncer la dégradation des conditions
de travail des personnels de justice ils
ont tous évoqué des personnels à bout de
souffle ils sont surmenés mais aussi
consciencieux ils ont aussi évoqué la
mémoire de leur collègues Marie Truchet
m'aura à 44 ans le 18 octobre dernier en
pleine audience je veux aussi ici lui
rendre hommage à Nanterre bien sûr la
situation elle est particulièrement
terrible parce qu'il n'est pas tenu
compte de la particularité de ce
département qui abrite le quartier
d'affaires de La Défense premier
quartier d'affaires d'Europe et
quatrième mondiale et donc avec des
contentieux à Fort en jeu financiers et
un travail long et technique mais ça ça
se fait aussi au détriment des affaires
ordinaires des gens ordinaires qui
réclament la justice les délaisses
d'instructions sont indécents quel sens
ça peut avoir devoir à 34 ans pour un
jugement divorce ou de violence
conjugales 15 mois pour des affaires
familiales 4 ans minimum pour les
prud'hommes 20 ans pour des affaires de
corruption
fin décembre président du tribunal de
justice a dû suspendre pendant six mois
et reporté tout le contentieux des
successions toutes les audiences de
culpabilité du tribunal pour enfants ont
été déprogrammés fin novembre faute de
personnels suffisants l'attente immense
des professionnels sur un forcément des
moyens alloués à la protection de
l'enfance et à l'assistance éducative
demeure c'est un supportable une justice
maltraitée ça devient une justice
maltraitante comme il le disent nous ne
voulons plus d'une justice qui n'écoute
pas qui raisonne uniquement en chiffre
qui chronomètre et comptabilise tout
monsieur
de maïs
monsieur le garde des sceaux mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président grâce au
travail combiné des états généraux de la
justice et de la mission sauvée nous
allons pouvoir réhabiliter l'institution
judiciaire et la remette définitivement
au cœur de la cité
la justice doit pour cela être plus
rapide plus protect plus retractrice
pardon plus efficace plus proche et plus
exigeante cela nécessite une
organisation structurelle et en
profondeur de nos institutions je salue
à ce titre la volonté marquée qui est la
vôtre d'une plus grande déconcentration
et ainsi d'une plus grande confiance
accordée au terrain cumuler au plan de
transformation numérique sur lequel vous
serez interrogé au cours de cette
audition et à la constitution d'une
véritable équipe autour du magistrat ce
sera sans doute le gage d'une plus
grande efficacité celle-ci doit
s'accompagner d'une plus grande
proximité avec le justiciable
l'application pour le ministère de la
Justice et la mise en place du passeport
et du droit pour les jeunes pour les
plus jeunes de nos concitoyens en seront
des outils essentiels
cela nécessite aussi une organisation
une réorganisation structurelle et en
profondeur de la justice le lancement en
janvier d'une véritable politique de
l'amiable en matière civile et à ce
titre un véritable progrès cette justice
plus participative et volontariste
permettra infinés une plus grande
rapidité et là aussi une plus grande
proximité tant recherchée par nos
concitoyens la césure et l'audience de
règlement vont ainsi limiter les
longueurs procédurales et permettre
juste ici de devenir de véritables
acteurs des décisions qui les concernent
enfin la modernisation et la
simplification de la procédure pénale à
travers une réécriture du code de
procédure pénale par ordonnance et à
droit constant et ce fondant sur une
smartera pardon un véritable tournant
sans modifier en profondeur la substance
de la matière pénale cette refonte du
code permettra une meilleure visibilité
et une plus grande cohérence de la
procédure le groupe démocrate salue donc
le plan d'action que vous l'objectif est
clair il faut rendre la justice aux
citoyens merci monsieur le ministre sur
cette première série de questions
le président est tout d'abord je vais
répondre aux trois interrogations que
vous avez exprimé
le référentiel j'ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'il avait été créé dans les années
et puis sans doute
délibérément oublié
Nicole Belloubet la ressorti j'en ai
demandé l'accélération il sera
expérimenté dans cinq juridictions dans
des temps très proches très proches ils
nous en tirons toutes les conclusions
qui s'imposent ça n'est pas on ne
regardant pas les choses qu'on peut
naturellement les améliorer
la place confiée au magistrat elle est
évidemment absolument essentielle dans
ces modes de règlement amiable il existe
déjà dans le code de procédure civile
des modes de règlement amiable je l'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure conciliateur
médiateur mais là c'est le juge qui
arrive c'est le juge qui se met au
milieu des parties vous savez ce que
disent nos compatriotes je dis tout à
l'heure la justice est trop lente mais
ils disent pas que ça c'est un peu au
fond comme si elle était trop lente mais
qu'elle ne prenait pas le temps de nous
entendre et vous avez des procédures
civiles dans lesquelles le justiciium ne
voit pas son juge
l'idée dans la procédure canadienne par
exemple que nous allons
importer l'idée que le juge MTT
honoraires magistrat dans certains cas
j'allais dire ordinaire
se mettent au milieu des parties tout à
l'heure monsieur Gosselin a dit
un peu justice de paix
et j'avais dit quand j'ai fait la
présentation à la presse répondante à
l'interprétation d'un journaliste c'est
un peu cette idée camusienne que la
justice est une chaleur de l'âme
on est là au milieu et on essaie de mais
avec Laura l'Imperium du juge et ça
change tout
et puis ensuite l'intervention des
parties
j'allais dire inciter par les avocats
qu'on va mieux rémunérer chaque fois
qu'ils vont vers une solution amiable et
puis naturellement dans la première
procédure qui est celle de la césure un
appel qui ne sera possible qu'une fois
que toute la procédure est terminée
parce que sinon pour ceux qui veulent du
dilatoire on aura des appels et une
embolisation bien sûr ce qui n'est
évidemment pas le but et c'est même
l'inverse du but que l'on recherche
je voudrais vous dire sur la miam j'ai
oublié de vous le dire c'est très
important
vous savez ma volonté de le mettre en
place d'inviter tout le monde à
participer à cette nouvelle culture on
va également associer les assureurs
c'est très très important ça les
assureurs parce que dans le cadre de la
protection juridique qu'ils assurent si
j'ose dire à leurs assurés
et ben il faut leur dire aller vers
l'amiable et j'ai demandé à la dipcom de
mettre en place une communication parce
qu'il faut aussi que les parties que les
avocats sachent que l'on peut aller plus
vite et qu'il faut tenter cette
expérience de la merde
vous savez
dans le procès en responsabilité que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
le demandeur il veut aller vite
mais le défendeur il a le temps souvent
il se dit plus adure plus il y a de
renvoient plus il y a de mise en état
etc
et moins vite je serai face aux
obligations qui sont les miennes si je
suis responsable la démarche c'est que
si le juge intervient étrange la
responsabilité tout de suite et bien
celui qui est responsable il veut aussi
sortir vide de cette affaire il sait que
par jugement il est condamné et qu'il
est responsable donc ça ça change au
cours des choses enfin dernière question
sur le président sur le tribunal des
activités économiques et non pas des des
affaires économiques bien sûr qu'est-ce
que l'on peut dire on va dire d'abord
que la frontière entre les différentes
activités aujourd'hui et de plus en plus
poreuses que l'activité économique n'est
plus réservée aux entreprises que ça
concerne les associations aussi bien sûr
les agriculteurs qui sont aussi bien sûr
des chefs d'entreprise d'où l'idée de
faire un tribunal dédié à l'ensemble de
ces activités et on fera dans un premier
temps une expérimentation pour voir
comment se les choses se passent dans la
monsieur le député Paris ce que vous
dites je le reçois
avec
avec bonheur d'abord parce que vous êtes
député mais aussi parce que
vous avez été magistrats donc quand je
parle quand je parle de choses
pratiquées ressentent les magistrats les
greffiers les agents administratifs et
les avocats au cœur des juridictions
vous savez évidemment de quoi je parle
et quand vous parlez de cela
vous savez de quoi vous parlez
je pense en particulier à toutes ces
questions organisationnelles quand j'ai
dit il faut aussi qu'on balaye nous
devant notre porte est-ce qu'il est
normal que tout remonte
en centrale
et l'embolyse d'une certaine façon et
manque de réponse et une forme
d'autonomie budgétaire indispensable la
confiance dans les gens de terrain c'est
pour moi absolument essentiel
c'est désespérant je pense en
particulier je l'ai pas évoqué mais dans
les mesures que l'on compte mettre en
place il nous faut un technicien
informatique dans chaque juridiction il
y a rien de pire que des magistrats qui
commencent à taper leur délibérés quand
la bécane tombera rade c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable ça ce
sont des choses qui remontent et que
l'on a évidemment entendu dans le cadre
des concertations alors les egies nous
disent qu'il est urgent de renforcer la
première instance de redonner toute sa
place aux Juifs civil qui traite on va
on va le rappeler j'ai dit tout à
l'heure 60% du contentieux et pour y
parvenir évidemment mais je souhaite
permettre au juge de se recentrer sur sa
mission dans notre exemple de
responsabilité c'est dire le droit
et ensuite les avocats les parties sur
le volet indemnitaire qui est beaucoup
plus factuel peuvent trouver un accord
au fond ici on est dans des ce qui est
insupportable pour les gens mais de
demander à tous ceux qui ont tué à vivre
un procès c'est cette phase de mise en
état qui est un terminal les renvois
expertise contre expertise enfin tout ça
c'est du temps en matière familiale du
contentieux par exemple relatif aux
droits de visite d'hébergement mais
enfin on touche à l'intime les gens ils
disent mais c'est pas possible que ce
soit si long et c'est ce qui fait que
77% des Français disent leur défiance
à l'encontre d'une institution qui
pourtant est à leur service avec des
gens qui sont d'une extraordinaire bonne
volonté alors il y a trois leviers il y
a l'équipe autour du magistrat
pour que les dossiers soient préparés en
amont de l'audience lecture synthèse
conclusion recherche jurisprudence
rédaction du rapport d'audience bien sûr
l'équipe n'a pas vocation à se partager
le pur juridictionnel qui reste
naturellement l'attribution exclusive du
juge deuxième levier c'est la mise en
place d'une politique de l'amiable je
l'ai dit je n'y reviens pas tout en
maintenant ce qui existe parce que nous
savons que il y a des conciliations et
des médiations trop peu mais nous avons
besoin des conciliateurs et des
médiateurs à qui je veux naturellement
rendre un hommage appuyé et puis les
avocats
meilleur revalorisation de de l'agi
chaque fois qu'on choisit d'aller vers
l'amiam et je souhaite aussi une
structuration différente des écritures
pour que et tous les magistrats l'ont
demandé ça
pour que leur travail et il faut
naturellement penser à eux soit
simplifier et allégé
monsieur le député est dit-on
bon je pense que vous mélangez tout
je vous le dis librement et sans
emballage d'abord ce qui a fait Nicole
Belloubet
monsieur s'était indispensable parce que
la mort était au rendez-vous la
contamination la maladie
oui et allez dire aux familles
des agents pénitentiaires qui sont morts
en prison
ce que vous dites
passons moi je ne veux pas je ne veux
pas
ah bon parce que la surpopulation pénale
au moment de la covid
non alors je vais vous dire quelque
chose d'abord
je comprends que vous ne sachiez pas ce
que j'ai fait d'abord parce que vous
n'étiez pas élu mais sa personne ne peut
vous en vouloir mais parce que vos amis
du rassemblement national n'étaient
jamais à l'Assemblée nationale a
commencé par Madame Le Pen vous faites
vous faites pas c'est une réalité c'est
une réalité le seul amendement qu'elle a
déposé dans mon souvenir c'est un
abonnement qui tente à ce que les
journalistes soient condamnés s'il vous
plaît à deux ans d'emprisonnement chaque
fois qu'ils évoquent des procès verbaux
des procès-verbaux couverts par le
secret de l'instruction voilà voilà la
réalité pour le reste les budgets vous
ne les votez pas il y a qu'à faucon
faudrait pour le reste monsieur dans le
programme très sérieux du Front national
en matière de justice ce qui vous rend
tout à fait légitime à critiquer ce que
nous faisons c'était 9000 magistrats à
une époque nous avions largement dépassé
ce chiffre et c'était la réclusion
criminelle la perpétuité réelle qui
existait déjà dans le code pénal depuis
belle lurette vous dites jamais c'était
dans le Livre blanc madame c'est vous
qui avez choisi la couleur qui
représentait le programme du
rassemblement national alors de grâce un
peu d'humilité vous comprenez maintenant
ah non je me calme pas Madame madame
vous n'avez pas la parole je ne me calme
pas
je pense que ministre est pourra vos
questions donc monsieur je continue à
répondre aux questions allez allez mais
madame ce n'est pas vous insulter que de
rappeler que dans le programme justice
du rassemblement national vous aviez
prévu 9000 places on avait déjà dépassé
chiffre d'ailleurs Madame Le Pen ensuite
rectifier le tir elle a dit 15000
1800019 non mais madame madame ce que je
dis est vrai
et
mais vous pouvez ricaner autant que vous
voulez c'est écrit c'est écrit madame
les paroles s'envolent et les écrits
restent
relisez-le c'est le vôtre vous deviez en
avoir un dans les archives mais et la
deuxième chose c'était la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité réelle qui
existe depuis très longtemps dans le
code pénal ensuite on vous a plu entendu
là dessus parce que naturellement ça
n'était pas sérieux bien alors moi je
comprends pas bien ce que vous voulez je
ne comprends toujours pas d'ailleurs
vous parler aussi migration comment on
fait par exemple pour envoyer chez lui
ainsi rien
ou un Afghan mais je réponds à la
question je suis je suis totalement
dedans vous voyez
bon avec vous on est au fond dans
l'anathème on est dans le conceptuel
enfin les concepts qui sont les vôtres
on a réglé que on a compris tous que si
vous étiez un jour au pouvoir il y a
plus de délinquance dans ce pays vous
alliez tout réglé ça n'est pas sérieux
la façon dont vous présenter les choses
vous savez je vais vous dire ce travail
voyez mais écoutez ce que de seconde
souffrait que je vous réponde ce travail
que j'ai l'honneur de présenter ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas que mon travail c'est
le travail de dizaines de magistrats
c'est le travail de policier c'est le
travail de greffier c'est le travail
d'avocat c'est le travail d'un comité
présidé par le vice-président l'ancien
vice-président du Conseil d'État de très
haut magistrats alors moi j'entends bien
que vous vouliez lutter contre ce que
vous appelez le dupont-morettisme mais
là Dupont-Moretti s'est effacé il n'est
intervenu qu'à la fin dans la vague de
concertation et souffrait que ce travail
ne soit pas le mien ce qui devrait vous
interdire quelques critiques voilà pour
le reste révisez vos sujets en matière
de justice parce que vous êtes à côté de
la plaque
je vous ai répondu complètement
complètement
si on peut continuer le propos du
ministre comme ça tous ceux qui ont
d'autres questions à poser pour le faire
regardez le niveau du niveau du débat je
vous mets face à vos contradictions
écrites monsieur écrite monsieur le
député
vous ne voulez pas les entendre mais je
sais pas ce que vous me racontez vous
comparez vous comparez monsieur Nicole
Belloubet vous racontez que c'est une
faveur c'était une mesure indispensable
c'était une mesure sanitaire à la permit
de sauver des vies bon ça vous intéresse
peut-être pas voilà pour le reste on n'a
pas bien compris ce que vous vouliez à
la fois à la fois vous dites que la
justice et laxiste je crois que madame
Martin attend votre réponse également le
rassemblement national a suffisamment eu
le l'honneur de cette commission oui
mais un dernier mot sur la sur la
justice laxiste enfin tout démontre le
contraire et les chiffres le démontrent
quant à la surpopulation pénale c'est
aussi la démonstration de ce que la
justice n'est pas laxiste allez passons
passons madame Martin
plusieurs choses sur sur le choix sur le
choix
sur le choix de l'ordonnance ce que je
voudrais vous dire que la cour d'école
au fond on écoute s'il vous plaît
sur
Madame la député sur le choix de
l'ordonnance
je vais vous rassurer sur le choix de
l'erdonant de l'ordonnance il s'agit pas
du tout de squeezer le Parlement
pourquoi la réécriture a droit constant
c'est un travail technique
et je le dis
modestement et c'est tellement compliqué
que j'ai mis en place un comité
scientifique il s'agit je le redis d'une
Reiki réécriture à droite constant et
sur la question des cadres d'enquête il
s'agit d'une simplification je vais vous
donner quelques exemples
il y a des délais qui ne se comptent pas
de la même façon il faut simplifier il y
a des articles dans le code de procédure
pénale qui renvoie à quatre autres
articles c'est-à-dire que les ça devient
un casse-tête pour les professionnels
il y a pardon je veux pas faire le
savant mais le diesel Cuesmes parfois on
compte les jours chômés parfois on les
compte pas tout ça c'est devenu
illisible et non seulement je ne veux
pas squeezer le Parlement mais je
souhaite la société de très près ces
travaux le président de la République
avait dit que pour ses travaux il
souhaitait que les parlementaires soient
associés ça fait partie de ma lettre de
mission et je demanderai au
parlementaire qu'ils veulent venir bien
sûr selon des modalités qui sont
précisées bientôt mais ce sera
naturellement éclectique voilà que les
parlementaires soient associés pour
suivre au jour le jour
mais bien sûr même vous monsieur
bernalicis
non pas surtout même non voilà mais tout
le monde tout le monde sera invité ce
qu'ils veulent venir viendront une porte
ouverte que l'on ne franchit pas n'est
pas une porte fermée mais je suis sûr
que vous viendrez voilà je vous rassure
c'est un boulot c'est un boulot
technique d'ailleurs il va prendre
vraisemblablement 18 mois 2 ans pour
dire les choses bon ensuite il y a un
certain nombre de mesures
il y a un certain nombre de mesures ont
dures qui vont venir et madame je
voudrais vous dire que toutes ces
mesures
opérationnelles ont pour but de
simplifier et il n'y aura pas d'écriture
du code pénal et de modification du code
pénal parce que ce que ce que les
magistrats nous disent c'est plus de
moyens de la simplification stop il nous
faut une pause législative et de la
réorganisation ministérielle oui mais
qu'on sait des mois que pour simplifier
dans une démocratie on peut pas abroger
de son propre chef on est quand même
obligé de demander un peu la vie du
Parlement non ou alors on est dans du
réglementaire donc prendre une loi
nouvelle pour simplifier c'est par
ajouter une loi complexe faut que vous
l'entendiez moi j'ai pas d'autre
solution si demain je souhaite par
exemple que sur l'exemple que j'ai livré
de contrôle judiciaire on ne réunissent
plus trois magistrats mais un seul bah
il faut bouger un peu les lignes
et cette opérationnel tout de suite et
c'est concret alors la PJJ armée je vous
rassurer là moi d'abord
ce sont des jeunes
volontaires deuxièmement il y a
l'expertise de la protection judiciaire
de la jeunesse troisièmement c'est
l'autorité bienveillante mais l'autorité
je le concède bienveillante de l'armée
qui va transmettre les valeurs qui sont
les siennes c'est-à-dire le dépassement
de soi la solidarité
et on a fait une expérimentation à
couette qui donne
ça marche c'est 80%
de jeunes délinquants qui sont sauvés
alors je il faut être il faut être
nuancé naturellement si la solution
c'était d'envoyer tous les gamins
délinquants dans les casernes je pense
qu'il y a des siècles qu'on aurait
trouvé et que ce serait réglé ça ne peut
pas être là mais il est un certain
nombre de jeunes que ça peut remettre
dans le droit chemin donc partenariat
PJJ armé on va profiter des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques pour
également
faire des partenariats avec la PJJ et et
le sport
création des centres éducatifs fermés je
veux y aller parce que les résultats que
nous avons sont des résultats qui sont
encourageants
voilà Monsieur Philippe Gosselin j'ai
bien aimé cette idée du juge de paix
c'est une idée que que je porte
j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est trop lent
mais en même temps vous occupez jamais
de nous on entend ça partout quand on
rencontre des justiciers
PPN je pense qu'on va beaucoup évoluer
fin 2023
il y a déjà un certain nombre de
procédures qui seront totalement
numérisés je pense au classement
les bords ruraux vont rester pour une
raison toute simple ça fonctionne bien
juridiction marche bien donc à pas
détruire ce qui marche quand open
plancher vous connaissez ma réponse
oui je pourrais avoir une faiblesse vous
avez raison monsieur le député
mais je ne l'ai pas je vous rassure de
ce président et le fait que vous soyez à
mes côtés et tu norme et non mais
monsieur Gosselin sur cette question moi
c'est
je suis pas un idéologue si franchement
je pensais que ça marche je l'ai déjà
dit d'ailleurs publiquement Go sauf que
Quentin ça n'a pas marché
et grandeur moi je suis attaché
à la liberté juridictionnelle et à
l'indépendance et je pense que les
peines plancher
je suis désolé c'est une entrave à la
liberté alors c'est des peines plancher
qui sont pas tout à fait des peines
plancher ce que vous aviez mis en place
parce que le juge avait la possibilité
de ne pas y aller mais alors ça sert à
quoi parce que s'il veut y aller
aujourd'hui bah il y va je veux dire il
augmente les peines auxquelles il avait
initialement pensé puisqu'il veut pas
voilà il est libre juridictionnellement
et notre justice contrairement à ce que
certains racontent partout n'est pas
laxiste en matière correctionnelle les
peines ont augmenté en 20 ans j'ai fait
de regarder les chiffres et en matière
criminelle c'est exactement la même
chose alors on peut perdurer à dire
c'est l'axis c'est l'axis faites rien
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs quand on en fait
la présentation c'est le ministre qui
est visé et cela qui raconte ça à
longueur d'émissions enfin de certaines
émissions ils oublient que le garde des
sceaux il ne donne aucun ordre à qui que
ce soit et que c'est disons le très bien
comme ça très
voilà ça s'appelle l'État de droit et
cela même qui critique la justice en
permanence ont une piètre conception de
l'État de droit pour te dire mais vous
allez me dire que je m'adresse encore au
rassemblement national c'est un propos
suis généreux
madame la député Cécile auteur Mayer
sur le référentiel je pense avoir tout
dit
c'est vrai que Nicole Belloubet a
souhaité exhumer cet outil que certains
avaient oublié en réalité mais qui est
très utile moi je l'ai dit c'est pas en
cachant les problèmes qu'on les règles
bon
monsieur le député Pradal première
question de bonjour Merci pour vos
propos encourageants je partage
évidemment vos préoccupations concernant
l'application des lois
et pour les lois concernant les ogj ben
le Parlement sera associé étroitement à
l'élaboration des textes réglementaires
réglementaires voilà ça me paraît bien
le moins puisque il y a en plus une
cohérence dans ce plan entre le
réglementaire et le législatif donc il
s'agit pas de faire le réglementaire
dans notre coin sans que vous y soyez
associés et d'ailleurs je me suis
longuement attardé sur les mesures
civiles qui sont déjà nous le savons
évidemment du du parlementaire
sur le les tiges circulaires
relativotige
alors d'abord je souhaite évidemment
développer les tiges c'est une c'est une
vieille peine mais elle est utile elle a
fait ses preuves il y a tout ce que nous
avons fait la plateforme 360 on a
aujourd'hui des des
petits-gistes qui pourront aller l'un où
ils ne pouvaient pas aller dans des
associations par exemple mais qui auront
reçu l'habilitation de la date
évidemment ça c'est la première chose
moi je souhaite les redynamiser encore
ces tiges d'ailleurs dans ma dernière
circulaire de politique générale j'ai
redit à quel point je souhaitais que on
n'oublie pas cette peine je n'ai pas
exprimée comme ça évidemment depuis 2018
l'offre de poste de tige est en
augmentation de plus de 43%
et on a aujourd'hui
34758 places de tige disponibles
voilà 26 000 postes inscrits actifs
3450 six postes recevant des mineurs
importants et pour certains d'ailleurs
c'est une première expérience
professionnelle bon
loi du 19 mars
2019 LPJ du 8 avril 2021 améliorant
l'efficacité de la justice de proximité
de la réponse pénale au corrige accrue
et puis baisse des pronostics en 2020
notamment durant la crise sanitaire des
prononcés de peine impliquant un tige
24000 sont revenus au niveau
du nombre prononcé en 2019 bon
moi je souhaite que l'on relance que
l'on
redynamise c'est une peine mais c'est
aussi une peine qui naturellement va
dans le sens de la réinsertion
et évidemment cette extrêmement
utile monsieur le député Jean Manoff
mon silence sur la réforme du statut des
parquets mais
je vous rappelle
que cette du Constitutionnel
il y a des travaux
d'accord
chaque chose en son temps il y a je
crois une réflexion sur nos institutions
puis je vais vous dire quelque chose je
j'entends parfois que le parquet ne
serait pas indépendant ça n'est pas
d'ailleurs ce que disent les
institutions européennes et non mais
quand vous fondez sur la cpège en
permanence vous voyez j'ai quand même
dire que la CPAS a deux ans de retard en
permanence puisque c'est la CPGE le
rapport de 2024 qui
prendront considération les
augmentations budgétaires qui sont les
dernières je vous le rappelle quand même
bon et je ferme cette parenthèse vous
dites contourner les tribunaux pas du
tout
c'est au contraire
c'est au contraire et vous parler de
déséquilibre entre les Parties mais vous
vous non mais vous mais même la césure
la césure il y a le juge et qu'est-ce
qui dit le juge il dit le droit et
ensuite il y a des avocats que l'on veut
valoriser notamment lorsqu'ils
interviennent à l'agit en étant mieux
payé
ensuite vous avez évoqué les seuils
mais les seuils notamment cette
criticité qui consisterait à organiser
des réunions avec les chefs de cours de
juridiction etc mais tout ça ça existe
déjà la date prévient
les magistrats qui sont d'ailleurs très
très attentifs à la situation carcérale
voilà sur le déséquilibre ben c'est
justement le juge qui permet qu'il n'y
ait pas de déséquilibre entre les
Parties c'est aussi son office
mais il aura dit le droit c'est à dire
non mais sur les faits on est ensuite
dans de l'indemnitaire comprenez que
comprenait que oui d'accord mais cette
présentation indemnitaire puis je vais
vous dire encore autre chose si vous
n'êtes pas content de la
de la médiation vous la quittez dire que
les autres procès ce qui durent deux ans
trois ans expertise contre expertise mis
dans l'état tout ce que vous voulez le
juge qui n'intervient qu'à la fin pardon
vous pourrez toujours reprendre
mais on peut pas avoir le beurre
l'argent du beurre on peut pas choisir
une procédure courte amiable consensuel
avec d'abord un juge et ensuite des
avocats et vouloir que vous pouvez pas
tout avoir mais non mais si vous estimez
qu'aujourd'hui une justice vendue dans
un délai de deux ans de trois ans c'est
une bonne justice mais 77% de nos
compatriotes
77% de nos compatriotes disent que non
donc il faut aller vers cet amial parce
que si vous étiez venu avec moi au
Pays-Bas si vous étiez venu avec moi au
Canada et mais je vous inviterai
volontiers mais je vous inviterai
surtout ce sera plus efficace et plus
rapide avoir ce que nous allons faire le
13 et comment les praticiens vont
t'expliquer à nos praticiens comment ça
fonctionne c'est pas un hasard si 72%
des Québécois utilisent cette procédure
ça n'est pas un hasard ça veut dire
qu'elle a fait ses preuves que la
justice est mieux rendue qu'elle est
plus proche qu'elle est plus protectrice
et qu'elle va plus vite voilà ce que je
peux vous répondre madame faussillon
m'interpelle sur la situation
particulière de Nanterre
sont vos mots sont pas les miens moi
j'ai parlé de simplification des cadres
d'enquêtes pour que pour que chacun pour
que chacun ait le propos même si
internet
c'est une précision sur la question
qu'il a posé tout à l'heure c'est sur le
rapprochement des procédures et sur
l'enquête de flagrance monsieur le
ministre
que me diriez vous monsieur le député si
je vous disais tout de suite
ce que le comité scientifique doit me
dire vous me direz vous moquez du monde
monsieur monsieur
bernalicis non seulement je vous dis
qu'il y a un comité scientifique
deuxièmement je vous dis mais vous ne
voulez pas m'entendre
que vous serez associé à l'évolution de
ces travaux donc
sur le boulot du comité scientifique sur
la réécriture
donc voilà n'ayez n'ayez aucune crainte
là dessus madame session elle m'a
interpellé sur la situation de Nanterre
bon j'ai dit tout à l'heure que dès 2023
il y aurait des magistrats des greffiers
et des assistants de magistrats qui vont
être envoyés dans les juridictions
pas autant que je le souhaiterais mais
vous allez comprendre pourquoi parce que
nous n'avons pas encore ouvert les
passerelles il faut le temps que les
textes entre en vigueur pour que nous
puissions recruter davantage et au
rythme naturellement où je le souhaite
mais dès que ce sera fait on verra la
différence bien il y a cette voie
d'accès aujourd'hui pour la magistrature
il faut envisager sérieusement de
simplifier les choses est-ce qu'il est
normal que
certaines professions soient soumises à
une formation de 31 mois alors que ce
sont des professionnels de la justice
voilà un certain nombre de questions
qu'on veut régler une fois encore sans
idéologie et sans dogmatisme bon ensuite
je veux rappeler que nous souhaitons
mettre en place un accord cadre sur la
qualité de vie au travail ça n'a jamais
été envisagé je souhaite faire vous
connaissez la liberté des syndicats ils
diront évidemment ce qu'ils ont à dire
et moi je souhaite que nous puissions
négocier cela ça réglera à l'évidence un
certain nombre de difficultés voilà ce
que je peux répondre et puis la dernière
chose c'est Monsieur
Erwan Balanant bon il y avait pas de
question il y avait des choses très très
aimables
pardon
bon
voilà c'était plutôt extrêmement positif
et extrêmement positif et j'en suis ravi
voilà ce que je peux vous dire Monsieur
le Député
qui reste 11 inscrits pour l'instant ce
que je vous propose c'est qu'on essaie
d'avancer et on fera une suspension pour
aller voter tout à l'heure entre 19h30
et 20h monsieur Gilles Legendre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux évidemment je n'ai rien
à ajouter aux appréciations très
positives exprimées par notre collègue
Didier Paris au nom de notre groupe deux
points très précis je reviens sur la
médiation dont nous avons tous compris à
quel point elle était essentielle dans
le plan que vous nous avez soumis et
porteuse de transformation et de
d'amélioration très très forte dans le
fonctionnement de la justice je voudrais
juste revenir sur un tout petit point
concernant le règlement à l'amiable si
ce règlement échoue
est structurel en France elle remonte au
19e siècle dès lors on a beau augmenté
les crédits chaque année la situation ne
s'améliore pas pierre elle se détériore
au gré de la multiplication des réformes
face à l'état de délabrement avancé de
la justice française et de la perte de
sens des professionnels il nous paraît
fondamental d'apporter une solution à
double détente une augmentation massive
et inédite par son ampleur du personnel
judiciaire corrélé à une amélioration
urgente des conditions de travail le
corps judiciaire demande une
reconnaissance de son travail de son
utilité sociale en outre il doit être
mis en terme sur le champ au phénomène
aigu de justice bashing dont souffre le
personnel judiciaire monsieur le
ministre on peut proposer de sécuriser
les promesses d'embauche 10000
fonctionnaires de justice d'ici 2027
dans 1500 magistrats or le référentiel
qui nous a permis d'estimer un tel
chiffre et théorique établi sur la base
d'une circulaire de localisation des
emplois largement sous évalués il
manquerait selon les syndicats au moins
5000 magistrats en France de surcroît 31
mois sont nécessaires pour former un
magistrat les recrutements à venir ne
pourront sont pas soulager immédiatement
les juridictions il faut également tenir
compte des départs en retraite et
ajouter les congés malades qui se
multiplient dues à la souffrance au
travail vous parlez d'entourer les
magistrats d'une équipe d'assistante qui
seront utiles combien seront-ils quel
sera leur type de contrat de travail et
quels seront la formation leur formation
si l'on devait aligner la France sur les
effectifs des états du Conseil de
l'Europe ayant un pays comparable il
faudrait porter le nombre de magistrats
à 13600 au siège et 7400 parqués or en
2018 ils étaient 8500 juridiction soit
seulement 1200 de plus qu'en 1880 alors
que la population française a quasiment
doublé monsieur le ministre et après
lecture de votre plan d'action comment
pouvez-vous nous assurer avoir pris
vraiment toute la mesure du problème
auquel la justice française est
confrontée êtes-vous prêt à travailler
avec le Parlement pour réellement
reconstruire la justice plutôt que
d'ajouter une énième rustine sur un
service public détruit je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Hugo bernalicis
merci monsieur le Président je veux
poser une question sur
un sujet qui doit tous nous préoccuper
qui est celui de la surpopulation
carcérale dans notre pays
72 830 six personnes
enfermées au 1er décembre record absolu
et chaque mois qui passe ce sera a
priori un nouveau record absolu pour la
France
2133 matelas au sol
si on prend que la maison d'art les
maisons d'arrêt parce que c'est là aussi
situation évidemment c'est 152% de
surpopulation
en 40 ans c'est important dans le
constat et notamment pour ceux à
l'extrême droite qui ne comprennent pas
trop le sujet c'est deux fois plus de
personnes placées sous-main de justice
en 40 ans deux fois plus de personnes
placées sous ma justice en rapport à la
population je parle pas en valeur
absolue en nombre par 100% habitants
plus 25% en 15 ans d'augmentation de la
durée de l'épine
et le résultat il est celui de la
surpopulation car c'est alors vous
pouvez nous dire on va construire 15000
places etc vous savez très bien que de
toute façon ça sera pas fait à temps
pour résorber la surpopulation qui a
lieu maintenant et on sait aussi que
quand il y a de la surpopulation
carcérale on ne peut pas faire un
travail correct en détention pour la
réinsertion des personnes détenues et
pour les personnels eux-mêmes ce n'est
pas du bon travail dans ces conditions
là voilà et donc il faut agir nous
sommes un certain nombre à défendre le
principe de la mise en place d'un
mécanisme de régulation carcérale qui
n'est pas un humérus clausus un humérus
clausus c'est on dit un nombre de places
et on fait plus rentrer personne le
mécanisme de régulation carcérale la
proposition est la suivante
on fait on fixe un seuil de criticité
c'est à dire le nombre de places dans
l'établissement et quand on arrive à
juste avant les 100%, ça oblige à
déclencher des Caps extraordinaires avec
des juges d'applications des peines pour
permettre plus rapidement la sortie de
ceux qui sont les plus proches de la
sortie parce que sinon de toute façon on
ne fait pas du bon travail
tout le monde y arrive et je termine
juste en disant même le procureur
général Mollens c'est un effet l'écho ce
matin sur RTL c'est pas une idée si
loufoque que ça merci
je peux vous renvoyer au discours de
Monsieur Mollens lors de la séance
inaugurale du conseil de la Cour de
cassation où chacun appréciera
l'indépendance du parquet y compris dans
l'empiècement des pouvoirs de la
législateur je me chargerai de dire ce
que j'en pense au procureur molens
puisque si nous en faisions de même je
pense qu'il en ferait lui aussi un écho
assez mauvais Monsieur Xavier Breton
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
garde des sources
pour les efforts qui étaient consentis à
la fois en terme de méthode dans ces
états généraux de la justice et
également des des moyens et objectifs
qui sont affichés maintenant il faut
avoir si effectivement ils sont réalisés
mais je tenais à le dire ceci dit dans
les 60 actions que vous avez présenté
j'ai pas trouvé mais peut-être j'ai mal
regardé les associations d'Aido victimes
tout le travail qu'elles font parce que
c'est elles font un travail formidable
et elles vont être aussi impactées par
la nouvelle organisation les nouvelles
procédures qui vont être à l'intérieur
de la justice mais comme elles sont
justement ce lien si important entre les
nos concitoyens et le monde de la
justice donc c'était pour voir aussi
comment elle pouvait être associée à ce
plan et qu'elle soit elle aussi
accompagnée dans sur l'impact que
corrompt toutes ces mesures sur le
fonctionnement de ces associations qui
encore une fois font un travail
formidable je vous remercie
merci Madame Blandine Broca
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux en effet on peut se
réjouir je pense quand même tous
collectivement de ces états généraux de
la Justice de la manière dont ils ont
été menés ils nous ont permis en effet
de prendre précisément la mesure des
difficultés que rencontre cet
institution mais par dessus tout
d'identifier les chantiers de
transformation que nous devons
entreprendre alors s'il en est un ici
que je souhaiterais citer c'est celui de
la transformation numérique du ministère
de la Justice nos logiciels sont datés
ont perdu tant le réseau est trop lent
je vais régulièrement à la rencontre des
personnels du ministère de la Justice et
je me suis vraiment rendu compte d'un
réel manque de matériel et d'outils
performants pour leur permettre de mener
à bien leurs missions il y a déjà plus
d'un an le procureur de la République de
Lyon Monsieur Nicolas Jacquet disait
qu'ils avaient absolument besoin d'un
réseau informatique digne de ce nom avec
des logiciels qui ne plantent quand je
vais faire un tour au greffe les
greffiers me montrent j'allais dire
comment duper leur logiciel et
d'ailleurs quand je me mets devant leur
logiciel j'ai plutôt l'impression d'une
sorte de mini tel le développement est
d'abord une organisation des études des
outils pardon numérique se révèlent en
effet essentiel tant pour les agents et
les magistrats qui estiment que
l'amélioration de leurs outils de
travail permettrait d'instruire dans des
délais notablement plus réduits c'est
évidemment ici notre objectif à tous et
c'est aussi l'objectif de nos
concitoyens qui espèrent un accès à la
justice et un suivi des dossiers plus
fluides je reprends ici les propos de
Jean-Marc Sauvé justement qui disait il
faut faire en sorte que les enjeux du
numérique soient pris en compte dès le
lancement des réformes alors pouvez-vous
nous dire monsieur le ministre l'avancée
de vos travaux pour permettre une
transformation numérique vertueuse du
ministère de la Justice qui
correspondent aux besoins et aux
attentes à la fois des agents et de nos
concitoyens je vous remercie
merci Madame Maria Takara mon lit merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez été les plus de deux
heures presque à répondre sur un seul
ensemble des éléments et je me
permettrai revenir un petit peu sur une
question qui a été soulevé déjà dans
l'hémicycle qui porte sur
sur la création de postes vous avez
annoncé 2500 magistrats 1500 greffiers
et vous avez aussi annoncé une
trajectoire budgétaire et est-ce que
vous pouvez nous confirmer qu'il s'agit
bien de création nette de d'emploi de
magistrats et aussi est-ce que vous
pouvez nous préciser les prévisions
d'effectif réels en juridiction dans les
trois années pourquoi je le dis ça parce
qu'en fait il existe parfois des
décalages d'une part certains supports
d'emploi peuvent être utilisés à
d'autres embauches comme par exemple des
contractuels pour une est limité de 1 à
3 ans
et d'autre part parce que si la création
d'emplois n'ont pas toutes effet dans
les dés juridictions de toute faite dans
des juridictions entre la création le
recrutement et la formation et la
nomination de magistrats et donc je
merais effectivement pendant de notre
groupe aussi et connaître un peu ses
éléments enfin vous avez évoqué enfin on
les avez évoqué indirectement la
question du statut du parquet ce serait
bien de recevoir un petit peu dans les
réflexions par rapport au statut de du
parquet au-delà de la Constitution
comment qu'est-ce qu'on fait en termes
de changement pour s'aligner aussi sur
les standards de la CEDH ça se doute
voilà c'est une réflexion que nous
pouvons mener me semble-t-il puisque il
y aura un grand chantier de réflexion
c'est c'est l'occasion et enfin je vais
leur revenir sur la question qui a été
posée tout à l'heure par ma collègue
Cécile ou ton ailleurs concernant les
dispositifs covid dans les prisons qui a
qui a contribué à éviter finalement la
surpopulation je termine parce que le
président
y compris même dans l'ordre de la visite
que j'ai réalisé sur une maison d'arrêt
230% de surpopulation au Mans
effectivement ça pose problème comment
vous allez dans les mesures que nous
allons être annoncées lutter vraiment
sur cette population de manière concrète
merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues les mares
ou mode de règlement amiable des
différents sont essentiels à notre droit
comme vous l'avez indiqué très justement
il permettent par une co-construction
des accords entre les parties non
seulement de désengorger les tribunaux
vous l'avez rappelé c'est à dire
d'accélérer les délais mais aussi de
pacifier les rapports et de bénéficier
d'une justice sur mesure adaptée aux
différentes situations
l'exemple du Canada ou des Pays-Bas qui
a inspiré votre réforme sur ce point
était éloquent puisque au Québec par
exemple le taux de succès de ces
procédures amiable et de
72%. le rôle des avocats qui doivent
devenir des avocats pacificateurs
notamment grâce à une formation adaptée
de qualité est également essentiel alors
vous avez annoncé la création d'une
nouvelle audience de règlement amiable
et d'une césure pouvez-vous nous
indiquer de façon plus précise la
manière dont ces audiences
fonctionneront et plus particulièrement
comment les différents acteurs de la
justice amiable les avocats les juges
les médiateurs les experts les greffiers
les conciliateurs s'intégreront à ces
audiences et par ailleurs comment
pourra-t-on comment pourra-t-on
s'assurer de la formation
de ces acteurs judiciaires à l'ensemble
des outils amiable qui ne s'improvisent
pas et qui nécessite plusieurs heures
d'enseignement
merci madame Julie le chanteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux mes chers collègues les
états généraux de la justice dressent et
ceux dès les premières pages du rapport
un constat particulièrement alarmant je
cite la justice n'a plus les moyens de
remplir son rôle ces mots sonnent en moi
comme une mise en alerte sur la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons la partie sur les délais de
jugement et particulièrement éloquentes
en moyenne en France et en 2023 plus de
14 mois sont nécessaires pour que la
justice statue sur une affaire en
première instance ou en appel 14 mois
qui nourrissent du ressentiment chez nos
concitoyens à juste titre la tenter trop
longue monsieur le ministre pour
répondre à toutes ces difficultés vous
avez annoncé dans votre plan d'action le
recrutement de 1500 magistrats 1500
greffiers et je cite d'un nombre
important d'assistant du magistrat d'ici
2027 à quoi ce chiffre fait-il référence
par ailleurs le nombre de magistrats de
magistrats reste insuffisant en effet
pour atteindre la moyenne européenne du
nombre de magistrats par habitant il
faudrait doubler leur nom c'est ce qu'a
proposé Marine Le Pen en 2022 dans votre
plan d'action il est indiqué que les
délais de traitement des affaires seront
supposément réduits grâce à la priorité
mise sur les audiences de règlement à
l'amiable les parties pourront être
renvoyés devant un juge qui les recevra
rapidement en présence de leurs avocats
si elles le souhaitent que signifie
cette prérogative est-ce possible de
parvenir à trouver une conciliation en
une seule audience les différents
évidents qui existent entre les parties
ne feront-ils pas durer le règlement de
l'affaire indéfiniment enfin quel est ce
nouveau rôle de conciliateur quand de
sera le juge celui-ci n'est-il pas
mandaté au contraire pour trancher le
litige je vous remercie
monsieur monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des sceaux nous vous avons
écouté attentivement lors de vos
annonces jeudi dernier nous vous avons
écouté attentivement ce soir je vais
reprendre l'expression de l'Observatoire
international des prisons qui dit que
vous ne proposez rien de nouveau pour
réduire la surpopulation carcérale
malgré la grève crise pénitentiaire qui
frappe notre pays
parmi vos annonces inquiétantes 1 la
généralisation du port des caméras
piétons pour les surveillants de prison
oui parce que c'est caméra de piétons
est-ce que c'est votre solution monsieur
le ministre pour pallier aux difficultés
de recrutement de personnel le mois
dernier je vous ai interpellé par un
courrier j'ai visité le centre des
tensions days dans le Lot-et-Garonne je
n'ai entendu aucun gardien de prison
aucun surveillant parler de caméra de
piéton en revanche ils ont parlé de
manque de personnel ils ont parlé de la
réforme des retraites ils ont marqué
qu'ils ont parlé de la revalorisation
des salaires ce que j'ai vu ce sont des
surveillants pénitentiaires qui
dépassent largement les plafonds de leur
travail certains plus de 150 heures 250
heures au cours du trimestre et qui se
retrouve je reprends les mots de la
directrice à travailler gratuitement
pour permettre à l'institution de
continuer à fonctionner vous fermez les
yeux sur cette réalité puisque alors que
vous n'arrivez pas à recruter des
effectifs nécessaires que le départ
d'agence sont massifs vous envisagez la
construction de 15000 nouvelles places
de prison
on ne vous aura pas entendu non plus au
sujet des recrutement des conseillers
pénétration d'insertion et de probation
qui connaissent les mêmes difficultés
qui sont en souffrance
vos annonces sont pour nous au nouveau
pas vers la maltraitance
institutionnelle les temps de nos
prisons ça a été rappelé par mon
collègue Bernal ici et le résultat d'un
problème de fond celui de l'orientation
notre politique pénale qui aujourd'hui
pénalise de plus en plus de
comportements renforcent les procédures
de jugement rapide comme la comparution
immédiate qui aboutit dans 70 cas à de
l'enfermement et allonge la durée des
peines aujourd'hui nous avons 2133
détenus qui dorment sur des matelas au
sol c'est inacceptable
ce qu'il faut ce n'est pas plus de place
de prison ni plus de surveillance mais
fait mettre fin et je termine monsieur
le Président cette politique de
surenchère pénale vous parlez souvent
monsieur le ministre de surveillant
acteurs il faut aller vers une déflation
pénale qui entraînera un déflation
carcérale et permettra oui au
surveillant d'exercer correctement à
leur travail Monsieur Eric Peugeot
merci président monsieur le ministre
notre justice est à bout de souffle et
le rapport des États généraux conclu à
un état de délabrement avancé de notre
institution judiciaire
vous avez présenté un plan d'action qui
souhaite je vous cite bâtir une justice
plus proche plus rapide et plus efficace
dont acte et Monsieur le Ministre ce
plan se résumé essentiellement à une
hausse de l'enveloppe budgétaire de
votre ministère dans un contexte de défi
en généralisé face aux institutions je
crains que beaucoup de voyants
malheureusement restent au rouge des
mesures de fond pour lutter contre la
criminalité la délinquance aurait été
appréciée elle palierait le
découragement des professionnels et
l'incompréhension des justiciers trois
mesures curatives seraient les bienvenus
tout d'abord une véritable suppression
du rappel à la loi ce que je regrette
son remplacement par un avertissement
pénal probatoire un palliatif dont la
vertu dissuasive reste à démontrer
ensuite comme le préconise votre
collègue le ministre de l'Intérieur le
rétablissement d'une double peine qui ne
soit pas facultative et qui permettent
d'expulser du territoire un étranger
condamné pénalement une fois sa peine
purgée
enfin la mise en place et on en a parlé
des peines plancher car la lutte contre
la délinquance passe par une
automaticité de la peine de prison pour
un récidiviste alors Monsieur le mini
sur ces trois derniers points quel est
votre avis quel est votre avis êtes-vous
prêt à les mettre en œuvre merci
merci Monsieur Jean Tarlier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux ma question portera sur
le volet civil de votre effort en vous
disant tout l'intérêt qui est le nôtre à
travers les deux procédures nouvelles
que vous voulez mettre en place vous
l'avez rappelé aujourd'hui ce
règlementable des conflits c'est 1% des
litiges je crois que c'est nouveau outil
que vous proposez c'est un véritable
changement de paradigme au fond avant
quand on voulait concilier ou trouver
une solution amiable c'est parce qu'on
voulait éviter un procès civile et là ce
que vous nous proposez en réalité c'est
trouver cette conciliation et où cette
médiation dans le cadre d'un process
civil sous l'office du juge et je crois
que ce véritable changement de paradigme
il est le bienvenu moi j'ai dans mon
expérience quand j'étais avocat je
faisais beaucoup dans le tribunal
paritaire des bourrerons et il y avait
une audience de conciliation qui était
obligatoire et beaucoup de procès se
résolventaient à travers cette audience
de conciliation ou au fond quand elles
étaient bien menées par le juge quand le
juge était acteur quand il indiquait aux
parties qu'elle était
le sens du droit et du conflit et bien
on arrivait à des solutions qui étaient
opportunes la limite de cette audience
de conciliation c'est effectivement que
le juge un moment donné acté ou pas de
la conciliation entre les parties et là
je crois que les procédures que vous
proposez vont permettre au juge de
s'inscrire dans le temps d'un suivi des
procédures et je crois que ça va plutôt
dans le bon sens
je voulais ma question me poser sur
notamment sur la césure je crois que
l'objectif est vous l'avez rappelé de la
césure c'est de réduire le temps de
procédure or aujourd'hui on le voit dans
le cadre de la césure pénale mise en
place dans le cadre du groupe code de
justice pénale des mineurs on a encadré
cette césure dans le cadre de délai
ma question était de savoir si il était
envisagé aussi également dans le cadre
d'être saisir civile de l'encadrer dans
le cadre de délai j'y serai moi à titre
personnel assez favorable au fond ce
serait quoi une mise en état un peu
obligatoire pour les parties pourquoi
pas pourquoi la prévoir peut-être que
juste sur l'audience de responsabilité
pas forcément sur l'audience autour de
l'indemnisation bref voilà j'aurais
souhaité avoir votre votre position sur
sur ces deux sujets merci merci rouleau
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les états généraux de la
Justice ont mis l'accent sur la longueur
des procédures elle insatisfaction
générale du justiciable ne se sentant ni
suffisamment écouté ni suffisamment
protégé pris dans les méandres d'une
procédure complexe vous souhaitez alors
monsieur le ministre à accélérer les
procédures et associer autant que
possible le justiciable à la justice cet
objectif est louable et nous le
partageons cependant nous craignons que
les moyens présentés ne parviennent pas
à l'atteindre pire que le premier
annoncé de la césure de procès civile
soit contre-productif ajoutant une
seconde phase à la première ainsi vous
proposez de couper le process civil en
deux le juge transférer le nœud du
litige les points de droit du paraissant
important et les parties s'entendraient
après sur les questions annexes pour
reprendre l'exemple le site en matière
de responsabilité le juge désignerait le
responsable et les parties le montant
d'indemnisation
on nous cite l'exemple des Pays-Bas qui
connaîtrait un réel succès de où la
procédure connaîtra un réel sur c'est
mais l'exemple prix à l'étranger n'est
pas forcément transposable en France
ainsi par exemple la médiation a du mal
à s'implanter ici contrairement au
Canada qu'il a pratique activement
depuis des dizaines d'années de plus et
surtout ce qui prend du temps dans une
procédure c'est justement de trancher le
nœud du litige de déterminer les
responsabilités pour reprendre l'exemple
on ne peut sauf à malmener le principe
du contradictoire pilier de notre
système juridique tranché un litige en
survolant l'épreuve où les arguments
défendus par chacune des parties on ne
peut déterminer une responsabilité au
doigt mouiller la détermination d'une
responsabilité nécessite du temps et
bien souvent des expertise c'est la même
qui allonge la procédure on ne voit pas
comment les expertises pourraient
intervenir après avoir tranché les
responsabilités dès lors ses principes
sont respectés on ne voit pas qui
permettra de faire gagner du temps
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre
répondre à nos remarques et nous dire en
quoi cette césure de civile serait une
amélioration un calendrier de procédures
n'aurait-il pas été préférable Monsieur
Jean-François couleur
monsieur le garde des sceaux dans votre
catalogue de 60 mesures vous laissez de
côté des enjeux pourtant bien majeurs
dont celui très sensible de la lutte
contre la délinquance financière et
fiscale sur laquelle nous souhaitons
attirer votre attention et celles des
Français
qu'en est-il des moyens que vous auriez
pu dans ces 60 mesures mobilisées et
étendre pour que notre justice attaque
sincèrement résolument à cette
criminalité organisée quelques chiffres
pour mesurer l'ampleur de l'urgence que
nous n'en doutons pas vous connaissez
très bien nous sommes environ 65
millions de Français et la fraude
l'évasion fiscale le blanchiment du
crime organisé se montrerait au bas mot
à 65 milliards d'euros par an pour la
traduire en souffrance sociale cette
fraude coûte donc en moyenne plus de
1000 euros par an et par français et
concrètement vous ne faites rien vous ne
proposez rien qui puisse remédier à
cette hyper délinquance et vous le savez
alors qu'en est-il de cette criminalité
financière pour laquelle vous ne pourrez
pas de mesures sérieuses mais qui
pourtant frappe la grande majorité de
nos concitoyens si destructrices de nos
services publics de notre système de
sécurité sociale et qui bien entendu
contribue à corrompre le financement de
nos retraites
en guise d'illustration de la connivence
de cette politique laxiste avec cela
même qui coûte au bas mot 1000 euros par
an à chaque Français fort discrètement
et comme par magie l'accès aux données
économiques sensibles des détenteurs du
capital des entreprises a été désactivée
sur le registre des bénéficiaires
effectifs des entreprises hébergées par
l'INPI et qui donc permettait la
transparence et la lutte contre la
corruption que mène des journalistes
d'investigation et les lanceurs d'alerte
par ailleurs qu'en est-il de votre
annonce de rendre le droit privé
français plus attractif à
l'international en matière commerciale
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pouvons-nous
monsieur le garde des sceaux espérer de
votre ministère des mesures réelles
déterminées et efficaces de lutte contre
ce siphonnage du budget et des moyens de
l'État par cette criminalité que la loi
actuelle quand elle ne l'encourage pas
protège
Monsieur Emmanuel Mandron mais merci
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux permettez-moi tout d'abord de
saluer la démarche des états généraux de
la justice et des différentes mesures
prises de puissance et que vous avez
présenté pour répondre à cette crise
profonde de la justice ma question porte
sur la création des cours criminels
départementales dont l'objectif affiché
répond sur un souci de rationalisation
et surtout d'enrayer l'engagement des
cours d'assises nous sortons d'une phase
d'expérimentation qui est apparue
suffisamment positive pour décider donc
cette généralisation des juridictions au
moment où nous entrons dans la phase de
leur mise en place il me semblerait
intéressant de prendre la mesure des
retours d'expérience dont nous pouvons
disposer
et le rapport du comité d'évaluation et
de suivi qui a été publié au mois
d'octobre dernier ça a été rappelé
apporte je crois un éclairage à partir
d'un bilan comparatif entre cours
d'assise et cours criminel
intéressant alors si des résultats
satisfaisants sont à salués quand on
respecte du format procédural criminel
et du contradictoire par les CCD il
convient de noter que le ce code même
comité d'évaluation a fait des
recommandations dans certaines recouvres
des alertes formelées notamment par le
Conseil de l'Ordre des avocats du bras
de Saint-Étienne et c'est encore une
fois le sujet de la faiblesse
structurelle des moyens humains qui est
en jeu
notamment lorsque l'on connaît la
dotation déficitaire en magistrat et
greffier par exemple sur Saint-Étienne
mais comme dans bien d'autres
juridictions alors la généralisation des
cours criminels est donc très
étroitement conditionné par le
renforcement des moyens humains je le
disais mais comment on va s'opérer cette
répartition des nouveaux effectifs année
après année
tiendra-t-elle compte des
recommandations du comité de suivi et
d'évaluation je vous en remercie merci
enfin Madame et
sur le ministre nous avons récemment su
que le nombre de détenus n'avait jamais
été aussi élevés nous y voyons
l'illustration de l'ensommagement de
notre société que le rassemblement
national dénonce depuis des années et
qu'il faut sévèrement réprimer et
dissuader malheureusement le rapport
sauvé
issu des états généraux de la justice
préfèrent entre autres proposer de
réduire les courtes peines la réponse de
la justice face à l'augmentation des
incivilités serait donc de diminuer les
incarcérations au profit d'alternative
aux peines avec vous notre justice n'a
jamais aussi peu fait peur au
délinquants monsieur le ministre malgré
votre arrogance votre mauvaise foi votre
haine du rassemblement national qui
confine à l'obsession et vos leçons de
Morales incessantes et absolument
déplacé de la part de quelqu'un qui a le
bilan que vous avez le résultat est là
les Français ont l'impression que les
méfaits qu'il subisse sont quasiment
jamais suivis de sanctions sur le
ministre je vais vous parler d'un grand
juriste du nom de Beccaria qui disait ce
n'est pas par la rigueur des supplices
qu'on prévient le plus sûrement les
crimes c'est pas la certitude de la
punition la certitude de la punition
c'est permettre à ses peines d'être
prononcé rapidement et c'est permettre à
ces peines même courtes d'être
appliquées grâce à une justice
suffisamment dissuasive monsieur le
ministre j'aimerais terminer en vous
demandant pourquoi vous préférez
concentrer vos efforts sur la diminution
de la population carcérale et non sur la
lutte contre la recrudescence des crimes
et la montée de l'insécurité d'autant
plus que je vous avoue ne pas comprendre
pourquoi vous voulez moins de criminels
et de délinquants en prison alors que
les prisons sont les seuls endroits ou à
ma connaissance vous vous faites
applaudir
si vous pouvez répondre en 10 minutes le
temps que tout le monde ait le temps
d'aller voter ensuite on va répondre il
y a des réponses rapidement allez
monsieur monsieur le député Legendre si
c'est la césure c'est le même juge qui a
tranché la question de droit qui
tranchera
je veux dire que la césure n'est pas
exclusive d'une expertise amiable c'est
pas l'expertise intervient forcément
après pas avant évidemment parce que
parfois pour trancher la responsabilité
on a besoin d'une expertise bien si on
est sur du règlement amiable procédure
canadienne c'est un autre juge qui
devra intervenir c'est en réalité
l'impartialité c'est l'article 6 de la
Convention européenne on l'a dit 72% des
procédures à aboutissent ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure monsieur
bernalicis
écoutez vous dites que je ne fais rien
mais
pardon mais la libération sous
contrainte pardon
non mais vous vous le dites de façon
collective et de l'autre côté on dit que
je suis que je suis totalement laxiste
ce qui veut dire que je suis peut-être
sur la bonne ligne voyez-vous bon
surpopulation vous le savez j'ai déjà
répondu vous m'avez reposé la question
attendons de voir la libération sous
contrainte ce que ça donne le but et
l'objectif premier pour moi c'est
d'éviter les sorties sèches qui sont on
le sait génératrice de récidive la mise
en place des établissements
pénitentiaire particulier pour aider les
gens à trouver du boulot à se former
avoir un logement j'ai supprimé je suis
le seul à l'avoir fait d'ailleurs grâce
au Parlement mais pas tout le Parlement
les réductions automatiques de peine
parce que je voulais les conditionner à
l'effort bon ça vous l'oubliez toujours
dans vos dans vos diatribes mais c'est
une réalité ça a été supprimé je vous
conditionne un effort à l'aune des
qualités de chacun j'ai dit que pour un
pour certains c'était se lever se lever
à l'heure le matin vous voyez ce
désintoxiquer travailler et apprendre à
lire à écrire se former etc etc je crois
que le sens de l'effort n'est pas un
sens interdit et moi je crois dans la
vertu du travail bon voilà Monsieur le
Député breton question très importante
je n'ai pas tout détaillé il y a aussi
un volet évidemment victime on veut
créer un guichet unique on veut qu'il y
ait une meilleure information des
victimes bien évidemment je pense en
particulier aux violences intrafes
familiales il faut qu'il y ait une
meilleure information de la victime du
début à la fin on veut développer pour
les enfants lui à peine
c'est quelque chose qui marche bien
c'est quelque chose que nous avons déjà
commencé qu'il faut intensifier
j'ai évoqué aussi la question du chien
d'assistant judiciaire je l'ai dit je
suis allé voir ça sur place c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne de façon
extraordinaire
j'expliquerai j'aurais l'occasion d'y
revenir sans aucun doute pourquoi on y
est allé il y avait une réticence qui
était d'ordre budgétaire le budget nous
donne les moyens de mettre cela en place
et il faut le faire ça libère la parole
des enfants point qu'un enquêteur nous a
dit moi je ne peux plus travailler sans
ce chien d'assistant judiciaire c'est
une espèce de de Doudou vivant et puis
ça libère la parole des enfants et ça
les aide donc oui les victimes sont
aussi au cœur de notre réflexion bien
entendu madame madame madame loro c'est
vous qui parlez de justice bashing enfin
c'est quand même le monde à l'envers
alors que vous critiquez la justice au
quotidien en disant qu'elle est laxiste
bon bref maintenant
pardon de vous veut dire que 7,5
milliards d'euros vous pouvez vous
pouvez qualifier ça de rustine mais
c'est quand même absolument
extraordinaire alors je vais vous dire
autre chose je vais vous le redire ne
vous en déplaise vous nous rappelez que
Madame Le Pen souhaite qu'il y ait 18000
magistrats dans ce pays je rappelle que
dans le programme livre blanc c'est 9000
nous avions dépassé ce chiffre il était
tellement ridicule que d'un seul coup
vous rend donc compte de l'inépsie du
propos vous avez doublé pouf on est
passé par magie de 9000 à 18000 18000 on
a même pas les lieux pour héberger les
magistrats c'est ridicule
non non mais c'est ridicule vous voyez
de 9 à 18000 en double allez un petit
coup de baguette magique voilà
décidément vous tromper sur tous les
chiffres tous les chiffres
18000 magistrats enfin pardon puis moi
je vais dire que c'est pas la Libye du
ministre ces chiffres c'est le travail
des états généraux de la justice et que
moi je ne suis intervenu que dans le
cadre de deux vagues de concertation
après que le rapport
ut été remis à monsieur le Président de
la République après que des
professionnels sérieux qui connaissent
tes besoins
et dit un certain nombre de choses et
vous vous faites l'un c'est
extraordinaire vous ne doutez de rien
porte-parole des syndicats qui eux
naturellement espèrent davantage de
magistrats et de greffiers ne sont-ils
pas dans leur rôle de syndicalistes mais
bien sûr que oui voilà les chiffres je
ne les ai pas inventés c'est pas au
doigt mouillé c'est après ce travail
impressionnant de plus de 8 mois
centaines d'heures de boulot vous vous
passez neuf à 18 pour y faire 36 aussi
36000 voilà c'est ridicule vous n'avez
aucun égard pour la justice si ce n'est
pour si ce n'est pour
critiquer l'étape droit critiquer
l'institution et raconter n'importe quoi
dans une espèce de réponse populiste qui
est un vrai semblable
madame la député brocard
on va évoquer deux secondes les outils
numériques je les dis je vous allez vite
je sais que vous avez vous devez aller
voter on veut zéro papier 2027 je l'ai
dit les juridictions
administratives ils sont parvenus on met
en place on en rediscutera de façon
précise avec le Parlement j'ai déjà été
interrogé à de nombreuses reprises et
c'est bien la moindre des choses on veut
mettre en place un applicatif qui
fonctionne pour tout le monde c'est
absolument indispensable pour régler les
problèmes actuels dont je sais que ils
sont insupportables pour les magistrales
et greffiers on veut mettre un
informaticien technicien dans les
juridictions
voilà je je pourrais développer
longuement mais je pense que je serai
spécifiquement
entendu par le Parlement sur ces
questions madame carrément lit création
nette oui bien sûr déjà 700 mag 850
greffiers 2000 contractuels je l'ai déjà
dit on veut pérenniser les contractuels
vous donnez très précisément le nombre
de contractuels je peux pas la
maintenant mais naturellement au fur et
à mesure et grâce à vous et bien nous en
définirons le nombre parce que il y a
1500 magistrats 1500 greffiers le reste
c'est contractuel et personnel
pénitentiaire évidemment donc on
affinera ça au fur et à mesure de
de la construction notamment
pénitentiaire mais il y a d'autres
éléments qui viendront en ligne de
compte madame la députée il y a dans
avocate spécialiste
de la médiation donc vous aussi votre
votre témoignage m'intéresse parce que
vous savez de quoi vous parlez voilà
attendez je vous ai pas encore répondu
madame la députée ne craignez pas la
foudre attendez
voilà bon je veux d'abord évidemment
non mais je veux d'abord saluer votre
votre engagement et votre conviction
pour la pour la médiation les mares bon
on sait que ce qui existe va rester j'ai
oublié de dire et votre intervention
permet de le faire
convaincuifier enfin codifier tout
groupé dans le code de procédure civile
parce que il y a des dispositions un peu
partout sur le mode amiable on va
évidemment faire beaucoup de
médiatisation pas de médiation mais de
médiatisation pour attirer les
Justiciers pour attirer les assureurs on
va parce que c'est votre question formée
évidemment école du barreau va devoir
s'investir école nationale de la
magistrature école des greffiers bien
sûr pour préparer et le premier
événement que l'on met en place le 13
c'est faire venir des praticiens des
magistrats qui vont nous expliquer
comment ils ont réussi ce que j'espère
que tous ensemble nous réussirons madame
le chanteur extraordinaire vous voyez
vous dites à la justice va pas bien
c'est vrai elle est en état de très
grandes difficultés ça sonne l'alarme
chez moi c'est l'expression vous avez
utilisé n'est-ce pas mais pourquoi
l'alarme s'éteint au moment du vote de
budget enfin pardon vous l'avez pas voté
c'est quand même extraordinaire fabuleux
vous faites le constat comme tout le
monde que la justice va pas et quand
oui mais pas pas en science
tous les budgets en tout cas toutes les
missions qui dépendent de la commission
des lois ont été votées en commission
des lois toutes
en séance vous étiez vous étiez pas là
pour le
vous êtes tous abstenus alors moi je
veux bien c'est curieux oui la justice
va pas bien vous dites ça publiquement
il y a des magistrats dégressifs qui
suivent nos travaux nos débats nos
échanges mais que diable pourquoi
pourquoi vous vous êtes abstenus je
comprends pas
bon ben voilà écoutez et vous avez
rappelé et vous avez rappelé 18000
magistrats et ce chiffre ce chiffre il
ne sort de nulle part
il n'était payé par rien il y a personne
n'a pu vous donner ce chiffre comme ça
non vous avez doublé je l'ai dit vous
êtes passé de 9000 nous avions déjà nous
dépassé ce chiffre et face au ridicule
vous avez doublé c'est votre choix et
vous l'assumerez monsieur le député
porte caméra piéton ça vous inquiète
mais moi ça m'inquiète pas parce que
c'est plus de sécurité pour les agents
c'est plus de transparence aussi et
c'est de nature à éviter quelques
agressions voilà pardon de de vous le
dire et sur les 15000 places il y a
aussi la rénovation des établissements
pénitentiaires et sur la surpopulation
moi je vais vous dire je n'entends pas
du tout comparer des situations qui sont
celles de la covid et Nicole Belloubet a
pris les bonnes décisions et puis des
au-delà d'un certain au-delà d'un
certain seuil on libéré mais les
Français ne veulent pas entendre parler
de ça non
et vous savez qui vous aider et quel
électorat vous vous mettez oui c'est ça
le risque vous voyez si mais si Monsieur
bernaliste mais bien sûr que si moi je
ne suis pas prêt je ne suis pas prêt je
ne suis pas prêt à dire que au-delà d'un
certain chiffre d'un certain seuil il
faudrait que des gens qui ont été
condamnés ne subissent pas leur peine
c'est un peu ça quand même c'est un peu
ça
non parce que l'objectif non mais alors
on arrête le dialogue je pense qu'on a
avancé ce l'objectif latéral c'est
d'accompagner on arrête et puis on pour
éviter
bon monsieur Poget le il est parti le
rappel à la loi c'était par l'un de ses
amendements que nous avons supprimé ce
rappel à la loi bon le débat sur
l'immigration etc va venir bientôt je
pense que nous aurons des débats très
riches quand open plancher j'ai déjà dit
ce que j'en pensais je n'y reviens pas
je ne vais pas répéter deux fois la même
chose le président m'en voudrait
monsieur le député terrier cherchant
délai je souhaite passer du double au
simple
on va expertiser ça on va mettre en
place un indicateur j'ai dit que je
rendrai public ce qui se fait en la
matière il y a déjà l'homologation dans
le délai d'un mois d'un accord bon je
pense que dans un premier temps
on peut faire ça et ensuite si les
choses vont parfaitement bien pourquoi
pas
je pense que la justice doit aussi
rendre des comptes de ce qu'elle fait
madame la députée rouleau bon
les procédures qui viennent de
l'étranger bon j'ai pas dire que ça
aussi ça vous inquiète ce serait facile
l'expertise on peut la faire dans la
phase initiale elle est partie bon c'est
pas bien grave voilà mais l'expertise
vous lui direz l'expertise on peut la
faire dans la phase initiale bon
monsieur le député Colombes
l'attractivité du droit français c'est
le rayonnement de la France il y a un
certain nombre de questions qui sont
extrêmement importantes la codification
ça permet en réalité d'avoir un outil et
ne le mélange pas et ne le confondez pas
avec le code pénal voilà les outils nous
les avons dans le code pénal les
magistrats tracent la délinquance
financière
ah ben écoutez regardez les résultats et
et vous verrez que ils sont extrêmement
extrêmement t'encourageant et que
d'ailleurs de l'argent qui est récupéré
permet d'abonder indirectement
naturellement le budget de la justice et
que l'on confie ce que de plus en plus
de bien que l'on distribue d'ailleurs
disons-le à des associations caritatives
on est allé expertiser ça en Italie
l'Italie avait une grande expérience
nous l'avons mis en place on a multiplié
les antennes de la grâce et c'est
quelque chose dont je suis fier
ensuite moi j'ai Roady dans ma
circulaire de politique générale qu'il
fallait avoir une tension particulière
pour la délinquance économique sur les
cours criminels départementales bon
beaucoup discuter là-dessus puis la
discussion
qui récente oublie le rapport
parlementaire que moi je n'oublie pas
qui a été rédigé par deux avocats de
surcroît Antoine Savinien et
Stéphane Mazar
il est périmé il est périmé il dit quand
même que ça marche assez bien il me
reste une minute monsieur le député
est-ce que je peux vous suggérer de
venir me voir la Chancellerie que l'on
détaille toutes ces mesures on fait ci
qui reste une minute non ce que je vais
faire c'est que je vais diffuser le
rapport qu'on a reçu sur les
départementales comme ça
et non il est pour vous il est pour vous
que vous citiez bekkarium enchante c'est
un énorme personnage dans la procédure
pénale mais je vous invite à le lire
c'est un très grand madame Diaz laissez
moi venir vraiment j'en ai pour deux
secondes c'est un immense humaniste il
était contre il était contre la peine de
mort et que vous en fassiez votre allié
à l'occasion de cette question
m'enchante madame
infiniment au fond au fond vous me
prenez pour le Gaucho de service
Taubira empire m'avez-vous appelé
monsieur bernalicis lui me prend pour un
répressif j'essaie madame dans le
pragmatisme qui est le mien d'être
humaniste sans être démago voyez-vous et
d'assurer la réponse pénale sans être
populiste c'est une ligne difficile à
tenir si vous y venez un jour vous
verrez à quel point c'est moins simple
que tout ce que vous racontez merci
Monsieur le Ministre donc la Commission
est terminée on se retrouve demain matin